all right and we
are finally live
the last word with lord cognito and
ivantis fresh on that friday
morning campfire big returning guests
that we can't wait to get into but
before we do
that ivantes how you doing sir
uh doing good uh i got a couple jokes
this week about my fridge
running but not running i actually had
my fridge die on me for a couple of days
so that's been fun
uh and then hats off to this morning my
ac is gonna just give me a little a
question mark so
the house is playing interesting um but
yeah i got to see the horizon zero dawn
like 14 minutes
pumped about that one uh we got some
destiny stuff to talk about but we got
an awesome guest joining us this morning
so
my stuff out of the way we got to bring
him in
so let's welcome him to the campfire
let's get him
welcome to the last word number 151
as guardians work to expunge the vex
network the tower is strife with drama
and pvp is about to get a big shake up
next week with so much to discuss we had
to bring in a very distinguished
gentleman
to join us around the campfire this
morning this man joining us today has
been doing this whole gaming thing for
quite a while as he is an nes baby like
the rest of us
matured gamers while those og games have
a fond place in his heart destiny has
become something truly special for this
man
it started at the character's selection
screen and he hasn't looked back
and why should he he is a legend in the
crucible an absolute lethal sniper
popping heads left and right and
clutching up trials matches for another
trip to the lighthouse and what class is
he rocking you ask oh
you know i'm excited that he agrees the
titan is the way
so let's welcome to the campfire a
member of last writes team mahamkara
masankoa which i'm probably saying
awfully wrong
i was close someone whose focus and
energy are always at an advanced level
for sure
he must have some special product in his
hair to keep it that good looking all
the time oh my god
but maybe he's just born with it he
enjoys a good rap and a beat but also
respects a barracuda as well
and let's end this right by reminding
you that he wants us
all to be better including himself
hailing from halfway around the world in
india
the highest of royalty himself king
allen how are you doing sir welcome to
the campfire
cake what an introduction
that's literally the summation of every
moment that i had like while streaming
that's crazy the barracuda i caught that
you didn't sli
you didn't i didn't let it slip you know
a lot of those things were there the
introduction of what is it the bungie
community focus i didn't miss that
either
great introduction thank you thank you
i'm doing amazing i had to go on a three
month break
uh i'm back feeling myself i feel good
i'm around very productive people
very creative people people who don't
say yes to everything that i do
people question me and uh people will
keep me grounded
uh when you're in that space your brain
is never lazy
and i feel good it just it feels nice to
be back
you know it feels feels good to be in
that space good to have you back man
definitely
you know big fan and love that you
address the mental health aspect and
just take care of what you need to take
care of
on the back end and i'm finally glad we
finally been able to do this we've been
trying
so long to get this done but i think
each of us
all had a situation that prevented it
from happening but we're here now
we got the king from india in the
building
so let's get into this gaming man look
forward before we get into dancing we
got to get to this gaming man you've got
some
real serious gaming history some
classic nes joints so let's start let's
solve for the beginning man what were
some of them real
titles that that got you sparked into
this gaming thing
so most people started with um
super mario right because you know
that's the og game like in some way
shape or form you played in mario
yeah i i started with adventure island i
don't know
how many how many people know that
that's what i started with
a dude running around and his underwear
you know throwing stuff
it was it was the coolest thing ever you
know like
and i'm from india right like it's
different the video games are approached
different
it's like such an unorthodox i'm talking
like way back then like you know my age
very small i had to beg my dad to get me
you know like
you're they don't call it like nintendo
or whatever so they
they plainly call it like a tv video
game that's what they call it here like
prefixed uh
names for it they just call it a tv
video game right okay
and i have to beg my dad all give me
this and give me that and
one you know finally got me it and i had
to go and get those biscuits you know
this those uh cartridges what are they
called cartridges
yes yes there's only four games that i
look for and i only found two
it was contra and adventure island nice
oh
that's a solid choice though
i used to just sit and just play hours
and hours and hours of it bro
and then i played bomberman like wow
classical astro uh
so many like i can keep going back
and just remember every title like but
the first
the first quote-unquote uh gaming gaming
experience was uh when playstation 2 at
the scene right
oh wait i i don't know if anybody knows
in india the playstation 2
blew up purely because of uh smackdown
here comes the pain
really right yeah yeah so uh
smackdown here comes the pain there was
actually tournaments that were happening
district level tournaments for for that
game
within teams it was crazy uh
that's when they started initiating this
uh you know people that they get
licenses
to have like video game shops so you
know
kids can come in and um you know and uh
you know play for an hour or two but
they have to pay for it and stuff like
that
uh that's when it became like crazy
crazy
i'm a g if i pick it up no everybody's
donezo like i'm that good at it oh yeah
you're like beast with it who used to
with the camera
i'm nutty with it bro like there's this
there's nothing you can do to me and
here comes the pain because
it was the thing you know it was the the
most in thing ever
you know and then you had to and if you
couldn't call yourself like a video game
like fanatic or whatever
like if you didn't know what that was i
was
putting in hours and hours into it it's
crazy
uh the funny thing is that that
here comes the pain at a career mode too
that you can create your own character
you can progress through raw timeline or
you know smackdown time lane
it's crazy for that time that game was
amazing
wow it was beyond uh beyond its time i
just got it i got a good question
not to cut you but like what was it
about that game that it blew up in india
so it was like do you was there specific
reason
character just promotion like why do you
think that's what the way it did
wrestling here is huge cricket is is
huge right it's the biggest thing ever
yeah and
uh wrestling is another thing that
people like
fawn over like it's everybody loves it
um that that has never changed that
that's always been a constant
because you can talk about rock and
everybody knows who it is
you talk about edge or they won't know
the actors and actual actresses
names or whatever in the movies right
yeah but they'll know every single name
in wrestling wow he used to be running
around with the
wrestling cards you know playing uh it
was crazy bro
i grew up in such a beautiful era bro
like
so many beautiful things and um
and like you said god of war ii released
around that time
when uh playstation released no
uh and when ps3 dropped that's when got
award three released
so those those titles were like great
titles
titles that like changed oh gaming was
gonna
you know absolutely yeah shift
completely
it was like i think god of war was one
of those prince
let me go back prince of persia started
it off
wow oh prince of persia
if you want to go even before the thief
started it all
thief oh there you go that's like the og
og og games like gog in fact yep
the like if you look at the global
spectrum
yeah the re there's a reason why people
remember god of war or prince of persia
or thief
is because the impact was bigger like um
and we all went through that we that
phase and we loved those games we played
it over and over again i i
i you wouldn't believe it the first
playstation that i ever got was a
playstation 4.
i couldn't buy one before that wow not
because of availability we were just
broke poorer they just couldn't get it
done
get it he couldn't get it and and then
when i was 17
when i was 17 years old um i started
working on my first job but whatever you
know slowly just small
jobs and stuff saved the money and got
my first playstation
ah man that's dope it was amazing
it felt so good my dad hated me but i
loved it
shout out to that hate i loved it i
loved it
he was not going to say nothing to me
because you know i was going to tell us
my money i wouldn't tell him because
he'll slap me but
you know because you pay for that
brother you pay for them right
yeah it's like exactly they're like hey
you if you earn this and you choose to
spend your money that way that was kind
of one of those things too is like
you got a job you earned your money it's
like and it's one of the nice things
about being a kid later on you're like
man i was if i didn't have all the other
bills that i have to pay for it's like
my job money went to
some dumb stuff at some point but i was
like that's definitely
part of your choice of like games i had
like a speaker system in my car those
types of things
that type of stuff over time you're like
yeah it's like those are those moments
where if you do work as a kid and you're
lucky enough to have a job and have some
disposable income
it's a fun moment or two in there for
sure the funny thing about indian
parents is
there's nothing you can do right unless
they approve
like it doesn't matter you can be right
you're just not right bro like
you just take the l bro like this
there's no there's no like if ands but
maybe
no discussions there's no discussion
there's no dispute there's no guy
in there there's no there's no none of
that none of that back and forth
so when i got it and i came back home
and i looked at
my dad i was scheduling
you know but i was like uh that i was
like dada
i i bought a playstation i've been
asking you for a while
and you know just often in the blows
like you you didn't get it from me i
finally have enough money i bought it
now
they know this is the rest of the money
i gave it to him and stuff and
he was like okay honestly
you got you got the approval you got it
you got the okay it's not like not look
resounding oh yeah i'm totally behind
this line
i was 17 bro
i was 17 like even though like they live
in my house no
um because i asked them to move in with
me they have their own house
i used to have company a lot and stuff
like that like before they
yeah i i just my brain doesn't allow me
to
do it anymore you know respect
or you know it's just respect
yeah i mean i still do my
i i go where i need to go
what you need to do bro you bit you're
being a good son
and taking care of the fan you know me
and that and that's much
respected i got one question but i gotta
let e get off because i know he's got
ton
of stuff he wouldn't ask too yeah no
it's just like i was like for you you
kind of covered part of it but it's
it i was like we're halfway across the
world from each other right
now so as you said there are some like
different cultural pieces in gaming like
even just what it's called for you guys
over there
yeah the fact that the thing that pops
off is a wrestling game
is just absolutely bonkers to me so it's
always it's kind of crazy to hear those
types of things but like on your side
before we kind of get into like your
journey in destiny and things of that
nature
um i wanted to kind of ask you to go
into
and if you're not watching this on
youtube uh he's got a cool thing behind
him on the wall
and i wanted to kind of just let them
know in like words what it is what it
comes from
and just kind of give everybody that
might listen to this but can't see it
what's going on because
some people get to see it some people
get to hear it so i kind of wanted to
shout that one out because it's a really
cool thing you've got on the wall behind
you so
i wanted to let you shout that one out
and explain that one if you would
all right so that that is the vision
behind
the kind of community i'm trying to
build and i have right now
uh it's inclusive compassionate and
unique
uh it means it's iec you as an
iecu
it's just that not you know i got you
i'm watching
even if nobody else is watching type of
stuff you know um
inclusive in its uh essence not not like
inclusive with the asterisks
you know like um everybody is welcome
everybody will be heard everybody will
be seen
nice because that's something that i
didn't have
and a lot of people you know like us
don't have
and um and i make sure that i make time
for
people in general uh no
i i personally the things that i live by
is the the purpose of being a human
being is to take care of each other
if you if you don't do that then
there's no point in living like period
this is nothing
not real there's no there's no there's
nothing worth living for
that's right most i don't know like i
used to be one of those
people like wasting life you know drugs
and
whatnot i'm even lucky to be alive and
that's because someone showed the
kindness that i don't deserve
so and it'll be a shame
for me to throw my life away and not
pay it forward and uh terrible people
and i
i swear to god i don't care what anybody
thinks of me oh
i don't want you to call me a good guy
bad guy
no matter what your opinions are of me
this is just me
this is all i am i i don't i don't care
no you're good brother you're good man
i love that story and i love that um you
know
basically there was a point in life
where you had to make some change right
and do some things to turn things around
and that's positive man and i love the
mantra because
we can all learn from that like you said
giving that energy back
you know from everything you went
through to now let everybody know you
got this is a safe space your community
you're including everybody you're
listening it's powerful stuff brother
you know and and salute to you for for
pushing that because
we need more of that we need from from
all over man
and i i got mad respect for you for that
so salute for sure for that
thank you it's a lot of work bro
you don't know like you don't know who
because the social space is built in
such a weird way
no matter what you say people always
assume that you're talking about them
yeah and you don't know how to
for me it's weird because i'm not used
to this like none of this is like
none of it makes sense to me because
where i come from
when i have a problem with somebody no
it's
straight up like like if i have a
problem
if i'm playing music to load i might
love to play music to love
but my uh i'm on the top floor
my neighbor will just walk up and you
know you'll tap my door from
the other side and he'd be like uh can
you reduce the volume if you can
because you know my baby is sleeping or
whatever it's very upfront very to the
face
you know right and i'll either tell them
i'm trying to enjoy this or whatever or
you know
it's okay i'll turn it down or whatever
it's very straightforward
there's there's there's no like
you know they they have a feeling
they're going they they going to tell
you how they feel
they'll do this just tell you how they
feel and you tell them how they
how you feel and it's it's
we we just know everybody and you know
we don't stop tweet
we just tell them he said hey no sub
tweet listen this is what it is
there's no stop tweeting like like if
i'm if i'm talking about something it's
personal to me
right i'm not looking for um
somebody else's approval of what my
feelings towards that
thing is you know right but most of the
time
people take it like that and you can't
help it and when you're pushing a
message
people put you in two categories right
if your platform is really big they'll
call you a really really good guy
if your platform is like small or medium
or whatever
right they'd be like oh he's doing it
for he's virtual signaling i'm like
who cares you can have all that i don't
care you can keep this you can keep the
like i started with 100 followers
right and nobody knew me i was talking
the same way back then i'm talking the
same way no
like just because you started noticing
me no doesn't mean i've changed
exactly consistent that respect yeah
yeah
you got to you got to yeah it's hard bro
it's hard in a sense because already
there's limitations you know
i'm not afraid to say it uh poc creators
are already restricted
right on top of that i'm from india my
restrictions are
limitless like the opportunities
available to me
um are already deferred by being the
color that i am
right and also the place that i'm coming
from also restricts it
and the opportunities available to me is
also restricted because of where i'm
from
right no it's true like what am i to do
i'm just you're doing me man that's okay
yep continue to do it brother continue
to do it because at the end of the day
people recognize it and for every time
you do that stream and someone sees you
that can relate that looks like them and
it looks like you and say you know what
he's doing it why can't i do it you know
what i mean and that's inspiration so
i feel you on that for sure for sure
yeah yeah
and and and the funny thing there's a
lot of things that happened to me that
that that rubbed me the wrong way
because i don't understand it
when i was pushing for this um tweet
servers for india by the way for
everybody who doubted me
i made it happen okay okay okay we made
it happen okay
okay let me flex real quick talk to them
service they don't understand how big
that is bro
like there were partner streamers from
india before me
fighting for six years to make it happen
and they gave up and they moved to
youtube
wow there was three three partner
streamers from india and they got
partnered
uh through some esports events and stuff
that happened here and
and and they tried to they had like
partnership managers and stuff for
back then for them when they hit partner
and then
it all died down and the partners were
the managers partner managers were
removed
so there was no back and forth between
twitch and them and there was no
communication there was nothing
happening
and and when i when i started this
campaign
the indian streamers in the audience
they they started talking to me
i mean my people are like that they're
very blunt to the face
they basically told me like oh you're
trying to do it for yourself
oh wow you're gonna get big or whatever
i'm like
bro my community is here i'm chill like
i'm set like i don't need this
extra exposure to this right the vision
is bigger
you need to understand that having our
own servers
allows for more creators to come in yes
because we have
i don't have internet issues like i have
a private lane that i pay for it's an
investment for me because you know
i'm doing this for a living so i have
great con internet connection
um but for most people here
it's very expensive right and um
having servers here the the ping and
everything is produced
yeah and they can and they can like
create and stuff or whatever
by the time i can gather all that like i
was torn exhausted because
i was getting hit from that side my own
people telling me i was doing it for cl
and then whenever i pushed it you're the
people don't even understand
uh what the issue is coming up and uh
telling me what is what and what is what
no
oh it's a business and they have to
think from a business perspective like
that's not your problem bro
that's them and me they can tell me
exactly what are you telling me
like yeah you have nothing to do with it
and
the conversations happen and then
somebody from early and uh one of the
twit staff followed me and
and then like i kept keep kept those
conversations happening and stuff and
people rallied together for it and
one day they just announced it okay
we're testing it
and then a month later it was live
one of my brothers from india works for
ign he put me into articles
uh ign articles for it oh so he's
awesome crazy
he actually messaged me and then he was
like uh hey bye
thank you uh he said hey chief thanks
for making this happen i like
uh like bro
a lot of a lot of people did it i i just
started it and just
everybody just came through and like you
know supported it and then
it was so cool like because you'd never
expect that to happen
and that was crazy that was crazy
huge
in a year there's so much
i've done and then it's it blows my mind
keep it going brother lucky bro i'm just
lucky i have like some of the greatest
people around me bro like
people with a big heart it's crazy
yeah because people see the energy
people see the energy brother that's
that's why it's glad that you came back
and you're still doing it and and at the
end of the day
people see the effort they see that it's
genuine and it's real and they're gonna
gravitate towards it
you know i mean that's just that's just
the way things work if it's real if it's
coming from a genuine place people can
sense it if it's fraudulent people
are going to walk away from it and
you're growing and you're growing man
keep it up brother that that's what you
got to do so we love we love hearing
this story
and hearing you growing and partnerships
and
all that this is good oh my god i'm so
backwards with it bro
uh before i i took the break no
my numbers were really really high and i
applied for partnership and stuff
i can still apply for it i just quit out
of the blue
because i had to and
people life happened and a lot of things
happen
and look some of my people were like
worried that my numbers won't get up or
whatever
would you quit and stuff like that no i
understand you're coming from a good
place
if i'm not happy mentally i'm not able
to
function from a happy place and if i'm
not able to function from a happy place
you won't get the same me that you've
been getting for
you know for a while now and you'll
notice that
and when you notice that you're gonna do
one of two things you're either gonna
sympathy love me which is not a bad
thing because i'm needy i'll take it
but but i you know like
or it's gonna set my mentality to
where i get complacent and i'm okay with
giving you subpar quality and i don't
want that either
like i'm very cognizant of the choices
that i make
so you know i had to talk to them and
let them know i need this like
i'm not in a healthy place like uh you
know
i came from a mindset of having suicidal
thoughts and stuff like that
that's you know when i got into drugs or
whatever back then by the way september
i'm six years clean and three years
sober
oh yeah uh that's what i'm talking about
so you know i didn't want to fall into
the again
so i had to take the break because it
was too much dad falling sick
and my mother is like acting crazy my
mom's
sorry my sister is pregnant now julie is
gonna be
you know the she's gonna come to term so
much going on and the covet situation is
crazy over here so like
you know like my dad anywhere too for
any like
is just too much and um it just like
it just yeah
yeah you needed some time it sounds like
and you had
and then i stepped away and i came back
and it took me a while to
to feel normal again because when you
go away for a long time and you come
back you even though people are
still talking to you with the same
energy you don't feel that
right you're like oh they're just trying
to talk to me because they feel sad
you know you know
out here don't ever forget that man no
don't forget that but metro
takes a while it takes a while to like
for that to
register in my brain like you know like
and it took me a good three
four weeks stumbling you know and then
i felt okay and then one day i was
sitting with i was sitting with
me is um amazing all day
like yeah he asked me to jump in a call
with him
um we're brothers like we talk all the
time every day dude
very good dude yeah yeah people who
judge him
i promise you you don't know his life
don't even get me started on um
so he messaged me and he was like let's
get in the call or whatever
um amaze my brother cube um
and faith on um we were sitting in the
call and a maze went off on me
what he was like what the what are you
doing
where's this allen that i know what are
you doing
[Music]
and i'm like i want to see you back to
you what what are you doing stop but
just calling yeah to get back to who
you're supposed to be yeah and and and
he was like
even if you're going to stream only for
40 minutes or 45 minutes do it
it felt like such a slap in my face
like honestly that's a good that's a
good friend who's able to be that honest
with you
and sometimes it's not everybody has
that type of person around them who's
able to just like
call you out and and sometimes that like
slap in the face metaphorically
sometimes but like
some of us need that sometimes so it's
like the fact that you got somebody that
can
that's awesome yeah and amaze would do
it in style too
oh yeah yeah he has no chill with me bro
he's got no chill with me bro like yeah
he was very blunt about it and he was
like what are you doing
just come back do you know for 45
minutes stream do it
then i did it the first day i did it for
a couple hours felt good
and then i started talking to my sister
like so can i
extend my stream for this many hours can
i i know i'll
i'll get four hours sleep and you'll be
able to get eight hours sleep and you
know i was managing it
and then i uh planned the 24 hour raid
day
but i started feeling so guilty after
the 12 hour mark i mean i finished the
day one raid
but i i wanted to keep going but i felt
very guilty she's pregnant like
i'm feeling some type of way and
you know spoke to her and like all right
i finished you can go to sleep or
whatever i'll take care of that
but you know i i got the when i tell
people they don't believe me bro i i
surround myself with people who
will hold me when i fall and slap me
when i fail
like that's real but that's real friends
though that's that's what it is you
don't you don't want
something no yes yeah none of that
i agree i agree like you don't want that
that type of energy because at the end
of the day
i always feel a good friend of it's kind
of my motto when i do iop
i always say i'm telling you what you
want it not telling you what you want to
hear
so i'd rather as a friend my friend be
mad at me because i'm being honest with
him
and saying hey what you're doing right
now you're going left
you know and i'm seeing it and i'll say
it so to keep that
around you in that circle that you're
talking about shout out to amaze
shout out to everybody you know what i'm
saying that's that's part of your circle
those are the real ones because those
are going to steer you right back
into what you're doing and it's good to
see you back you're doing the destiny
content we got great
stuff out here to play you know what i'm
saying they got that that var grade that
you're carrying
everybody sorry we transitioned a little
bit into this uh
destiny a little bit yeah so it has been
quite a crazy week since basically we
talked last we had mark on
getting ready to go over you know the
pre-launch of vlog our speculations of
what was coming
and then saturday hits so i kind of
wanted to jump in
first and get into this past week has
been
mostly i would say focused on except up
and someone say yesterday
uh mostly focused on vlog for a lot of
people vault of glass coming back into
the game
how it felt how your runs went so um
cog i wanted to check with you it's like
not to take away from our cast but
vlog is his baby so i wanted to reach
out and see how contest mode went see if
you were able to jump back in before
reset
if you got it done um if you got your
raid ring on order like i got
to get i got to get the whole story yeah
i got to see like where are you at with
vlog right now i gotta go
listen man um it was it was it was
interesting because
you know coming in i kept my
expectations very low vogue
is very special to me as y'all know you
know i've been i've been capping for
this raid
for all my destiny life you know it's
it's it's the single reason why
i played destiny to be honest because i
was kind of done with the game
you know initially playing it like a
traditional game thinking
that once you beat the campaign it's
over and in the console space
you know there wasn't anything like a
raid or anything like in-game content
and my friends tell me hey you got to
get to level 30
whatever whatever i'm like ah i already
beat it like you know it was okay
you know kind of thing but then doing
vaulted glass and just
the little things of forming the spire
and
you're just this you're like what is
happening and you're just
going deeper and deeper and then the
aesthetic of this vault and
you know it's just all these variety
counters so you know
for me coming in i was curious like what
are they really going to change what it
what is
really going to happen and then is it
and i'll be honest i got to check myself
be like was i
more prisoner of the moment back then
because it was the first
or is it truly a great raid and
now that i've had a couple runs you know
contest mode was rough i will be honest
um
temp law was a big damage that dps check
i mean you talked yeah we both
yes that was the call for both of us
templar was rough you know i said but
getting there
i did like a lot of the subtle changes
and the first thing i got a shout out
was
shout out to the simon says oracles
a little bit on that one had to learn
had to learn you know just not
as simple as shooting those things you
know during the confluxes
i i first let me back up just one second
ain't even going a lot contest mo just
forming the spire was a little real
or contest no it for sure was
definitely not the usual on that one it
was
yeah we i we started there and i i
didn't have a set group shout out to
those that i got to play with
um but
just like if you don't have
like a set group you're kind of not used
to how people are gonna play who to
depend on whose cover and what
and you know it's like i got my brother
in there which was cool to actually get
him in a raid on the first day he got to
experience contest
he's not a huge fan of contest but
that's okay
but like he stuck with it and that was
the cool thing so for as long as we
could i ended up having like dinner
stuff so we gave it about six hours for
the first piece
came back just got about almost
everybody together for a few more hours
on templar but just even when you
started vlog it was like
the the portals opening and it was just
it was the addition of the cyclops
yes that really started kind of ruining
everything and it was just that feeling
of
the way contest you were just getting
just the crap kicked out of here for a
little while
because you're like yeah it doesn't
matter how strong i might have been
you know you're 12 you're 1300 this
stuff's hitting to me at like 13 25 and
then all of a sudden
yeah oh yeah all of a sudden you're like
i'm trying to stagger some of these guys
you get into a rhythm
and like one of you gets one shot and
then the other person dies and then your
whole platform's just like
overrun by like 50 dudes and you're just
like
takes you like 10 minutes to finally get
things settled and then you look over
across the map and the other side's dead
and it's just like
yeah that was kind of the way it started
i'm like i don't even know if we're
going to get through this
i was not sure at first i was like
and we finally just like we finally got
enough of like
continuous like two plates up and slowly
but and finally it
hit and i was like oh my god we got it i
was like i was so surprised at first
because
it felt like it was just like we were
struggling and when it finally happened
i was like i
didn't honestly expect it to even happen
when it did so yeah no they definitely
contest is real no matter when you face
contests like because we i saw it like
deep stone [ __ ] the eight tracks wall
was
that was a 12 hour wall and i gave up
after that one but
no like contest is contest takes so
much precision so much precision so much
um very small margin of error like if
you die and it's
you may as well be doing a hard mode
rate in destiny one because if you die
in contest you pretty much will throw
everything off
yeah you thought you throw it off so
it's it's real
yeah and that's exactly why i want
contest mode to be a permanent structure
in destiny so for vaulted glass
the reason i didn't raid with my
original team is because i didn't want
to compete this time
um my original team uh we competed for
dsc we placed top 19 in the world
so yeah it was the first time like i
wanted to rip india and do it
and my team was like solid we ran
through it was pretty good it was pretty
good
we actually beat the first two
encounters before everybody else and
then we got to
get the third yeah when we get stuck at
the third encounter it was dope though
because
it was my it was my first uh i mean i've
gotten day one clears for everything but
it was my first i'm gonna compete you
know yeah yeah
i didn't wanna i didn't wanna do that
for walter glass because
walter glass is just eat so many
memories for me to
rush through it like i just wanted to
enjoy it
i just wanted to so i played with my
some of my
friends that i wanted to play dsc with
in day one
that team so i just switched over to
them and we played
we finished it wasn't that hard it's
purely because like we were all like
already ready for it right you know we
we expected
all of this you know we expected uh uh
yeah you know how bigs were annoying
when was the glass dropped right we
prepared for that level of annoying
yeah gotcha you know so everybody had
one mine built everybody had like dps
bills ready to go everybody had
everything ready to go
that was rdps i was going to say that
was one of those weird things sorry to
interrupt but that was like
being in vault of glass and having those
like seven year memories but also
realizing now you have the arsenal that
you do in destiny 2. yes yes i was like
this is different because like just
whether it be the boat the breach load
grenade launcher that it had just like
busting up a door every so often and
just like your arsenal definitely gave
it a different feel granted
honestly that's probably why they did
have to crank it up so much but it's
like when you said war mine cells
yeah like those like this yeah some
power and i forgot that existed
yeah because your mind everything cracks
yeah it is a lot bro like just that you
can you could have controlled the entire
you know activity with just one mind
there's warm mind cells that suppress
all the enemies
completely there's cells that completely
blow everything up
you know the cells that i love you to
take reduce damage
you you if you have one person running
you know one each you know one person's
gonna surprise one person is gonna
you know blow everything up it's it's it
it was sad
um it was it was it was fun
our dps was tested when we got the
atheon
[Music]
there so let me back you up though let
me back you up so templar
you guys were fine with templar yeah we
burned them
so what did you use what did you use for
templates you guys got double shotguns
yeah what was that what was it what was
the strat double slugs
that was like slugs so you just like um
you did like tedx you disappeared
[Laughter]
like you had the warlock with the uh oh
well you had a bubble like what was the
yeah
that's the same like uh we had one
bubble we had one well
everybody else said uh chaos or noah
they just switched up in the moment
um the the trouble that we had was
purely in atheon because eighteen was
giving us
stolen it felt like he was not taking
damage at all even with the best weapons
facts and i tweeted about it immediately
and like
it feels like he's not hurting at all
like no matter what we do
and then like um we we had two people in
our team who didn't have a bridge
oh yeah yeah preachers oh wouldn't have
breached i mean it doesn't matter
because
even if one person has it like it's fine
yeah everybody gives we wanted to check
if all
six can breach and if it's tax oh yeah
that won't do it
yeah and then we wanted to check it it
didn't work so
um what we did was uh we had one bubble
we had two titans with a chess piece
thundergrass and we had uh you know two
warlocks
um it took us like i don't know eight
nine attempts before we cleared it
once we declared it though still
impressive yeah
um once we cleared it though that that's
when brain starts working like
oh middle tree chest piece fusion aids
unlimited fusion does 100k like what the
hell
it starts clicking in and stuff like i
was reading um
right salt grappo and his partner they
were saying
they went back to d1 and they two-man
the entire raid
uh over and over again just to
understand the position
yeah right and the placements of
everything right they prepared in that
level
wow to compete in world first you know
what i'm saying like
see that's honestly what i figured
somebody was gonna do like beforehand i
was like
if you have access and the servers are
still up to go back
and experience what it's like in d1 and
you know you people do under mans and
stuff like that so you low man
probably set up their gear in certain
ways and as you said like they
if you could two-man that whole thing
then you add more people there then
you're just like okay now you can just
supplement everything
you know this is just free at this point
and then
it was pretty dope it was pretty though
and i i
you know after i finished the day one
i didn't want to do challenge because
you know i wanted to relieve my sister
and stuff and i came back
and the only challenge i did was ate the
on challenge okay oh
well that was the hardest one just to
feel good
i just want to do the atheon challenge
and and and
yeah yeah man i don't jump in because um
yeah it was like i said contest mode
first it was it was fun just getting in
there
seeing how far you can get away with you
know not knowing and what strats are
working and stuff like that yeah
you know for the for the temple i want
to back up for the tepla fight
you know actually before the templar
fight the confluxes was interesting
because you had
now the harpies and the champions
that was the white ones are so much fun
bro like
i didn't even expect it when i saw it i
was like
i was like okay because i'm like yo i
see big boy in the back
i was like something's going on so we i
think i had um
i was hailing them with the um agent was
it the agent ordnance rocket launcher
yeah yeah that was really good yeah yeah
that was really chocking them so i had
that i had that bill going on
so he was doing that and then like i
said templar was was pretty
fine you know we the the what what was
happening was e
well i think me and you talked is top
goblins were
hurting like
one shot in you oh they would get you so
that was kind of affect us a little bit
and then we didn't have the
the strongest strat against templar at
first and we figured it out but then
once things went on
the eighth year on fire i forgot we're
gonna get to the gore guns and all that
but i gotta talk about the eight year
old fight for one thing
because like you were saying alan like
for us it was the same day i'm like damn
i feel like we got the strongest weapon
i feel like we're doing we're getting
out of each time zone
on time but i'm like why i don't feel
we're
hurting him hurting him right were you
doing that on content did you get to him
on contest day or no
no no we didn't get the ammo contact
even after i still
felt it a little bit so i was just
trying to i was figuring out and then we
had to change some things up obviously
thunder crash titans but some what we
were messing up
was actually a cup i don't remember if
he did this before but it was two things
one
during the dps phase demand is harlem
shaking
he wasn't doing that before i'm like
what is this
yeah so i was like that was the first
thing then the second thing
and this is smart my budgie but it was
so frustrating for us
the team is detained so we're yelling
out yo
who got to detangle above then
who got the book get out because what
would happen is that one person is so
focusing on dps yeah and they're not
looking they jump and then the whole
squad and i'm like oh
man not even ashamed i ruined the the
the clear for us at
one of the runs he was he was like
literally 10 hp
and i i threw it and nobody got mad at
me everybody's like
cool this
and stuff like that but that that was
said i wanted to mention that
now again to go back i really
gorgon was interesting you know i said
god i was interested
yeah when you're like oh i gotta go find
the boxes to open it as opposed to yeah
just like right that was fun bro
yeah i was like i'm out there like
hunting around trying to like peek
around the corner and we got to back up
a little bit
and then the one because i went because
there's like one on the right one on the
left there's
kind of the three there's one in the
center where i could get to in the
center i'd be back far enough and i
could see like a sliver of the corner
and i'm like pew you could barely pluck
in the corner and i was like i got it
and then i'm like i'm not coming back
we're dying by the way
when you come back yeah the fact that
they can hear the jumps like you hear
like the floofs and
they're looking up and i'm like yeah you
gotta be yeah you gotta be a little
a little higher a little quieter they're
a little more sensitive in time
the fov increases your fear now
yes because you can see everything
and and you know the you know the moment
that like completely like shook me
was when the
uh when the atheon entrance opened
yeah it like it was
the music he cleaned all the music it
was so
good bro it's so good it is beautiful
bro
yeah i got some nice screenshots on
there yeah i saw your screenshots it's
beautiful
it is really like it's it's an epic
situation once you get into that room
and you see it like i said i think what
it is overall
it's one it's the aesthetic i still
love before this different stages of the
atheon encounter
the shield mechanic going in there
passing it off
doing that part yeah some of that stuff
yeah obviously like gatekeepers
doesn't feel as good as it was before
like i don't know
like you can't which part like the the
skating with it
like it's you can still skate with it
not as efficiently as before
and also like sometimes when you block
you can't shoot through
and i don't know why that way that
happens well yeah they took away the
cleanse at templar which was very good
they took that away yeah i mean i guess
wondering on templar because it used to
be to where if you were doing templar
that
um i can't actually even think of how
the hell it went
basically like people would just sit on
one side not worry about the oracle's
cleanse
and then go do it so they kind of took
it out of the equation they're like no
no we're gonna
force you to make sure yeah
so i like yeah i like that part at least
engaging with the encounters and you're
like
okay i kind of get it like the cleanse
would have been nice but
i guess they have to take away the
cleanse otherwise they did cheese it
before this so they made it we had to
engage a little bit more
yeah if if people are upset
i'm just putting in this whole if people
are upset about vaulted glass getting uh
getting new you know mechanics and bring
being brought into contest mode i cannot
wait for bungie to rework rata the
machine and bring it back
everybody's gonna cry everybody's gonna
cry
basically that raid is probably one of
the
hardest team base raids bro i love that
raid
it's the best raid if you don't take
lower into consideration
rather than the best rate big lauren i
would say rather than one of the most
fun
yeah i would say rap is one of the most
fun ways i would always give that to
wrath for sure
but again like you you just said it like
lore will
hurt it you know what i'm saying but now
yeah king's four i gotta defer to e
like that is lore like there's a lot of
lore
a lot of bosses a lot of mechanics a lot
of cool encounters but
for e i'm just curious because you know
obviously
king falls your baby you know what i
mean and i don't i don't remember how
much
experience you had in d1 with
full like i'm trying to remember like
you're you're history i played plenty of
trust me yeah i was forever 29 not
getting gallicorn
no i believe i spent many mini moons i
wasn't
that was like the crew that i originally
started playing with so we actually had
like a tuesday rating group that we
would play on
multiple characters and clear through i
mean you did normal mode and then i was
forever 29 waiting on a helmet for i
can't even remember how long
a buddy of mine had more almost filled
up his entire heavy slot with gallihorn
copies before i got my first
wow so i was like yeah he had that one
forever so it's like it that's kind of
one of those things i actually wanted to
ask you guys too
is with all the raids that we're talking
about
obviously destiny had the main four
we've now seen
vog but you got king's fall you got
crota you've got
um obviously wrath and so
of those three first question borvog
itself
coming back the way it did it's in the
legends category
and that's literally the only reference
to
it this is like an archive of old
content there's no story implications
with the vex there's no
other edition going on there's no
mention of it in the world it's just
here's another experience in the game
before i even get to the other question
i wanted to get you guys thoughts on
that piece for one
and then two if they do bring something
back like and even vlog didn't have a
whole lot of connection to the story per
se before it was a cool activity
if they bring something back like king's
fall
without any connection to story do you
still
does that take anything away from it for
you guys or do you still just enjoy the
experience that's there
okay for veterans i don't think it'll
make a difference
because uh we know everything through
and through page for page cover for
cover
you know like uh and for us it's
the way we consume it is basically all
it's our raid but
in 4k you know yeah pretty much it's our
raid in 4k
but for the new people there it'll be
like the new light players playing the
new light mission like the entire
storyline they wouldn't
and if they wanna you know understand
what it is they have to invest
themselves in the game
and the group more and you know destiny
one grimoire
is still the best at me i'm telling you
like this
this whole reading the groomer through
this uh you know through the game
i'm not a fan i like to go to the
website turn all these groomers and read
it
you're one of the rare ones don't know
that's right i like it
in the game lord all right though he's
standing on his square though i respect
that he's like yo
this is what i like continue yeah and
then
that that is something that they
shouldn't have taken away i don't know
why they did i don't know why they
brought it back inside the game instead
the game was so corny i don't want to
read it like it's so
like it's it's not something that we
used to read
more let's be honest we used to read
groomer after we ended our session and
when we were
when we read it that's when we used to
read it now if i want to read it i have
to
i have to open the game and go to a
certain page
okay i get that having access to like
having access to the lore books outside
of the game
which i'm sure there's websites that do
um but having access to those outside
the game for you it's like hey i got
like some down time like
i'm chilling at work or it's like hey
it's like you need some bathroom reading
whatever you want to do with your time
but it's like i mean
you never know where you're going to be
reading that's kind of one of those
jokes but
yeah like be having access because i
honestly haven't gone through most of
the books in game but i think the
ask of so much of the community to say
give us this stuff
inside the game and i'm honestly loving
the last two seasons of storytelling
like in your face is even the best
but still having access to be like if
it's in the if it's at least in the game
and i'm in there it's like i can at
least go read it you know if you want to
and some and you could not do that
before you'd like pick up a grandma card
and then have to go out and
like the your website and read it and
it's like that that was kind of
disjointed
but i do get if there was like hey the
bungee website had access to all of the
lore books now because they're in book
form
like if you unlock them on your account
you potentially could go on the website
and read them just like
have reading on the go wherever you want
it so i get that for sure
but i don't think they shouldn't have it
in game personally as well
right yeah i mean preference no it's
preference it's
more so like like people tell me like
life is great to uh you know
involve yourself with laura and stuff
like that now i don't need bite for that
i need by you or when i'm trying to fall
asleep because this voice
that boy that voice is soothing yes
yeah i i'm not trying to learn or
get in what does it get into the story
through his voice his voice is just
calming and soothing for me that's why i
listen to life you know
it's it's different reasons but when i
when i get into something i want to do
it you want it
for you yeah i want to do it like and
that's all like i feel good about it i
feel like oh
i'm in the story i'm part of this you
know i'm the guardian and you know
it feels good i get it i'm not on that
train but i
understand because the reason why i do
understand your point
again is that there was a part of me
in d1 that let's be honest you're in
front of the game you're playing a game
for hours upon hours right
having fun right so during the gameplay
sometimes necessarily you don't want
like how it is now to just to be
distracted by reading something in game
you want to be playing the game
whereas in one for the people like
yourself that
love it separate it was almost like
still playing destiny when destiny was
done you were still
having yourself engrossed in this story
when you're away from the game so it's
like you can't wait to come back to it
so i do i do get that point to an extent
you know i'm saying i think for me it
was just like
i always felt like it was a missed
opportunity because
i would defend the game to people that
hated on it
and they were like oh that ain't got no
law this the story is yeah and i'm like
no bro this story is great if you read
these grim
oh why i got like casual guys like oh i
gotta go outside the game
like they would attack me and they'd be
like what type of game doesn't have the
story in it
so really it was more of bungie catering
to the majority
saying you know what it's an option in
here
you know you go just press the tab
whatever but i do understand
where you're coming from i do want to
think about it around the casual topic i
want to clear this up for anybody who
has those if you clock in more than six
hours
a day on destiny you're not a casual
[Laughter]
talk to him you're just not a casual
please don't
don't don't use the label hey don't use
the label if you if you clock
more than six hours every day in this
industry
not a casual
i don't get it how can you call yourself
a casual i mean you
casually play the game it's different
from i'm a casual
thank you bro you hardcore played the
game but you hardcore play the game
casually
be like you know they got hundreds and
hundreds of hours
like i didn't feel i got anything out of
it so i'm like you're like
what were you doing with your time like
that's kind of one of those is
you can and it depends on what you have
access to how dedicated you want to get
into anything because if you
want to get into something deeper all
you got to do is look
now some people are going to be
intimidated by lfgs and that piece and
that's kind of one of those you could
have like
a lot of bad experiences and i fully get
that i've had some
ups and downs in the lfgs over the years
for sure they're not all bad they're not
all great you never know
i was like just don't take anyone
personally and move on
my lmg experience is history bro
the the person that taught me how to do
king's fall was a quaggan
a friendship forever i'm telling you
put yourself out there there might be
ten bad people but that one good person
you find is worth it yeah
absolutely it's like i used to do
teaching in that as well it'd be like
there were certain points would be like
i will do this like i'll handle this you
guys handle these pieces especially
king's fall
like i would help do i used to teach
stuff more when i was actually in that
and help explain more things than i do
now
um we bought just a shirt but i'm
finding out now
yeah i was like when i actually get into
raiding oh i was like i
used to like honestly just run them more
than i do now now i'm just a bit more
casual about it
but even as you said there's like
there's levels of account but yeah if
you play hundreds of hours like
it's a hobby you just may not be like
you know high hardcore
or practicing your skill or anything
like that but like yeah if you play with
hundreds of hours you're not
casual but if you want to go if you want
to practice and get better that's on you
you can grab practice can get better in
50 or 500 hours just depends on your
skill levels
yeah it's hardcore gamers without a
purpose that's what they are
they're not casual gamers they're
hardcore gamers without a purpose they
don't know what they're doing they don't
know what they want they just play the
game just to play the game you know but
they play it
because they're so habituated with it
and they just want to keep going and
going and going and going
like if you pick the game or you pick an
activity you pick destiny
and you want to go do an activity you're
probably going to go raids or you know
or nightfalls or whatever right
and examples i'm not saying you're only
a pe player for example
like but i'm picking i already know what
i'm going to go play i'm going to
calm profiles so that's that's where
i'll live since vlog is here i'm living
there so
uh you know it's it's it's we have that
purpose
you know like this is what i want to do
what do i want to do this i want to farm
spoils
get that god roll fade bring her actual
fracture yeah
i have every role you can think of well
he's probably been farming spoils and
stuff but
give me visual vision and confidence i
haven't seen vision once
i'm stuck on fatebringer i have at least
four
i have five five fate bringers yeah i
have five
but that i've been getting fatebringers
heathens
and corrective measure i finally got a
piece of armor yesterday for my titan
and i could finally look at all the ma
i've unlocked like 10 mods
i finally got to see him yesterday yeah
i haven't been able to touch him
my rng my rng has been good in terms of
like the overall loot but vex has been
like
just evading me i've gotten every armor
piece every armor piece
wow or except for uh the
i'm missing the mark on titan i'm
missing the cloak on answer and i'm
missing the gauntlet on warlock
only that's that's all i'm missing right
i've gotten all the weapons
all the way wow i have 50 of fate
bringers in my
in my uh vault right now that's a lot
more every variant you can think of
i have the what is the god role for fate
bringer in your opinion because
some people may or may not know so i
mean
i personally would go for uh explosive
payload an
opening shot for pvp with the
amorphous accuracy range master what
about
stability master pve
it's uh obviously one range and
it's fire play and explosive payload i
have that
explosions are freaking beautiful i got
fireflies
and payload i don't think i have the
great other half but i have firefly and
explosive payload
at least on the same roll the other half
probably isn't amazing but
yeah it does yeah it's like the firefly
is fun to hit with the hand cannon for
the explosions for sure it's decent
hitting one foot and something about it
i don't know if you don't know the
payload and pvp you know why they like
it
it makes your hitbox bigger yeah and
it makes your land crit charts easier
like it becomes easy to handle
when you combine expose a payload with
firefly and even when you shoot vexes
even if you aim lower or higher it'll
automatically go to the quick
quick spot and hit it and it is just
it's just so clean up i love the way it
fires off at
the zone
oh it's amazing what you were saying
about your about your uh fate burger
oh it's just like the it's something
about the 140 the feel but it's like it
feels
good like we remember fatebringer
feeling good and fatebringer still does
feel
feel good because hand cans are in a
good spot and then on the other side as
you said people are getting vision
people are getting hung juries and
they're like
don't even care it's like vision what
and that's kind of the sad thing about
the archetypes right now where some are
great and some are not
and we talked about kind of the state of
some of this before but it's like now
people are getting vision and it's like
okay just sit that away you can get 12
of those and it's like it's a scout
rifle right now it's like and it just
doesn't
it doesn't do a whole lot for you
because there's so many other options
that are probably going to work better
so i will say in
for oracles and certain parts
scouts were actually i mean before we
knew about the
the what you call it the uh xenophage uh
and war by itself strat what other
articles with the the proper mods with
the bow you don't even need xenophages
anymore
is it with the is it with the oracle
mods though is that what you're talking
about article mods and i'm saying i'm
finally actually getting where i can toy
around with that stuff with the armor
mods but i haven't been able to try that
so i've just had to hit them otherwise
what's the mod what's the flow with that
what's there so there's only one mod for
bose
the position article yeah
it's basically those were strong i was
actually using a bowl for the day one
and i made everybody in the team
switched to a bow too
it was so easy to break it if you get
that mod i'm sure
even without the mod you're fine it's
really strong both are really strong
okay so two two swabs ago
manji released uh saying that we are
monitoring dmt
and you know we know it's so strong and
stuff that's that day i tweeted about
the archetype issues i said scouts are
the weakest weapons in the game right
now
yeah they are they're literally the
weakest weapons of the game right now
they need a buff however
bungie cannot selectively buff certain
archetypes of scope rivals
that will put dmt as the strongest
contender
in its archetype and they can't buff
that archetype either because
hip fire needs to be butchered in that
weapon alone
specifically before that archetype was
buffed
so i tweeted about this and nobody was
talking about it when i
when i tweeted about it because you know
nobody's thinking about it because
everybody could talk about stasis or
you know dmt or whatever you know a few
weeks later when in the
vlogs here and vision of confidence is
dropping and people start to realize oh
this
weapon is so underwhelming this used to
be great what's happening
and and then you know you start seeing
videos
coming out saying that it doesn't even
one-shot trolls it doesn't even one-shot
this it doesn't even one-shot them
i mean this is expected rifles are
they need to be buffed yeah they need to
be brought up
but be con because the minute we talk
about um
uh buffing scope rifles there's going to
be a group that just chases bungie
to the you know heavens and earth until
they nerfed dmt
right you know they have to move
carefully they have to navigate
carefully when they
when they try to talk about buffs and
nerfs and stuff like that because
bungie doesn't owe anybody anything
they're the only company that
that are being as transparent as they
are no company does it like
which which organization do you think is
as active and as they're very engaging
as they are
we got to give them back yeah absolutely
yeah yeah they're definitely near the
top
as far as i'm concerned you paid 80 for
the game
you played this game for four years the
thousand
four years yeah yeah four hours yeah you
got your content you're good it's a live
service game
and the the situation is not like very
welcoming
is you know i'm i'm i wrapped the pvp
site
hard no we haven't had content for over
600 days oh that's a fact
that's a fact yeah and and it hurts me a
lot because i love playing that
and it hurts me a lot but i can also
understand
you know we're not able to go to work
or offices because code has been
nonsense like you know like
it's the same situation for them and
it's and
the minute you talk about that but it's
they've been doing this even before that
or whatever
the visions have changed they they've
changed as a company they had to let go
of certain partnerships to
you know navigate themselves through
other places or whatever we take
their calms their communication for
granted so many times
and as yeah as a community we don't
we we're so entitled bro we're
entitled we're so entitled and people
don't even notice it
it's like they're demanding what are you
demanding for you paid for the game and
you played for four years bro it's a
life service game
you want more pay for it like you know
if they take that mentality no
that's when people start realizing oh we
took them for granted when they were
you know right i mean strives really
hard to be
honestly one of the best in the
community like dege trained them very
well to be
active about a lot of things and you
know you see him out there with iron
galaxy hopefully setting up something
really cool over there too which is
awesome art of it too though is
they're very they go through these waves
of lots of transparency explaining
what's going on
and then there's other times where they
are noticeably cagey about well
pvp is a prime example right now even in
this 12 which we haven't got to yet
we get to talk about stuff that we're
getting changes for stasis which people
are really
excited about but then it's like the
other half is
you know you know they mention about
gameplay and stuff like that for
abilities
but that they they just talk about the
sandbox there's still no question of
like
modes reworking pvp comp being useless
no ladders
there's the list of things that i've
seen you know many other content
creators like
make of how could you rework this
between cuj
and ascended nomad and the ways like you
could change it up
and i know like my eyes still are
sitting out there at which queen
hopefully seeing something but it's like
you get to this point and you
finally have to ask like there are some
things they're really clear about and
then there's other times we go through
one swab it's like hey here's clarity
of like .50 damage and like changes here
and there's other things like
yeah you get some more damage here it's
like they're oddly vague sometimes or
kg and then other times they're
completely open so it's always just like
they do like honestly we're spoiled with
how much we do get
from them but they're sometimes
leave some very important stuff out that
would be nice to get more even in game
i'm sitting there with like chat
sometimes
why can't we see like the aim assist
stat on a gun why can't we see the
recoil direction
it's on light.g it's on every other
website in the world why is it not in
the game so there's some things that are
so just this question this thing that
you brought up where you know
certain things are they're very vocal
about certain things they're not vocal
but or whatever yeah
i'm i'm very like things like this pop
in my head no like i don't keep it in
i immediately add them and ask them
straight away like
i had dmz and you know um epione
before he quit uh before he left banji
right they clearly said that they don't
have the information to give
i mean either they've been informed not
to tell us anything
right or they really don't have anything
to to tell us
and then and then us continuously going
back to them asking them the same
questions
you know and they're giving us the same
answers right we can't be happy about it
either because
the the the the pvp state is still a
hurting
i'm part of it oh yeah and and the comms
i'm sure they want to say something to
us right
in some way shape or form right but you
know they they can't openly talk about
an anti-cheat but
according to leaks and anti-cheat is
coming next season right uh
they can't talk about uh new maps or
game modes or whatever
like from a consumer's perspective like
i can think of so many things
that they that they didn't bring in from
d1 that they can just put into d2 and
it'll be a massive hit
like rift you know it'll just be a
massive hit it'll be phenomenal
i don't know why it's not a game mode
you know but
i don't understand why they couldn't
like straight away disable stasis only
in pvp
because spaces was still selling point
for you know obviously the
beyond like dlc and i understand it they
could have disabled it in pvp and left
it in pve
because both sandboxes are separate but
they didn't do it
like i have a lot of questions like this
and
every time we engage with them
they're responding to us and it's it's
feeling like
starting to feel like either they're not
allowed to give us the answers
right i mean that's generally what it is
yeah yeah yeah or or they just
don't know what it is you know well i'm
thinking i gotta
go no i was trying
i personally just don't think that they
don't know i think they do know
is just again i think it's a situation
what they're willing to reveal
at the time with it listen these these
studios
have white boards and they're talking
two three four seasons out years out
you know they've got a timeline but it's
it's how they're choosing to disseminate
the information yeah
yeah and that for us it seems like oh
they're being quiet they're not
but it's it's it's according to their
schedule when they're ready now some not
gonna agree with it so i'm agree with it
but i don't want to beat this to them
e go because we got a lot more to talk
about and we got spaces and we got stuff
i want to talk about yeah so i mean the
big thing
that obviously dropped in 12 they talked
about vlog they'll talk about the raid
race go read the interview it's pretty
cool
um but the big thing talks about kevin
giannis jumping in to discuss the state
of pvp
uh what they're trying to do and they
kind of go through with a little bit of
history they've got some throwback to
like halo quotes in there which are
pretty funny
um main pieces that they're saying
there's four main points
uh yeah that they're trying to work on
and when we set out to define what our
vision looked like for the future of
guardian vs guardian combat
it boiled down to a few key pillars
weapons are the primary way players
engage with combat
non-super abilities accentuate or
augment the combat but should rarely
solve an encounter by themselves
abilities have clear strengths
weaknesses and counterplay
build crafting is rewarding within the
moment-to-moment gameplay
combat loop of destiny and they say
behind the scenes we've been
executing on these pillars by planning
out a road map of patches that we
believe
will not only get stasis where it needs
to be for pvp but also sets up a shift
to shift the pvp combat sandbox in a
meaningful meaningful way toward gun
play
so we don't have to go through all the
details and all these pieces but that
generally covers some of the some of the
main points before we get into stasis
right i mean you listen to firing range
you listen to most people talk about pvp
and they're just like
it is abilities a lot so many abilities
in pvp being a common thing
so many people not having gun fights or
just charging in with a shotgun and then
trying to use stasis for a freeze
we'll get to the stasis changes in a
minute but
for them one bringing the stasis patch
sooner
which we got word that that's actually
coming literally thursday instead of
waiting for
some time in august which is a surprise
that's a big push and that honestly took
them some development effort to get it
sooner
because they pumped that thing what is
it because you have june july and august
basically almost three months before
that thing would come
and we're getting it here at the start
of june so two and a half months early
on a patch
that shifts some focus for them for
development
but the main focus like where do you
guys do you guys think those are good
things for them to go for do you think
abilities are too strong
um light versus you know dark subglasses
whatever you want to say on those like
for the main pillars they're going for
do you think these are good pillars for
them to shoot for and do you still think
do you think they can execute on these
things as well
well let me jump in because um this one
was very important i was very surprised
to see this this was a
very impactful 12 i did not expect this
i'll be honest you know i've been on
their
head allen as far as when are you going
to talk about pvp
what's going on right now does this
solve everything
as far as what i want as far as maps and
the focus no but
it helps explain what a little bit of
what's been going on
and to me what i learned from this there
was an
internal priority shift that let's be
honest the majority of the community was
like
i am done with stasis that was the
consensus now i'll be honest
stasis for me i'm i'm a fan of it i'm
not crazy of it in pvp
but in pve i love it i truly do yeah
it's one of my main classes in pve
just controlling but in pvp obviously
the hardcore they were upset
so to the point where they're like yo i
don't even want to deal with crucible
because of it
so i think what i get from this is
bungie said look
let's address this because like we said
earlier all of this stuff when stasis
was coming out people complaining
and then they're adding new augmented
adding new fragments and stuff like that
because the road map was all again we
got to think like those artists
they had that set uh it wasn't like yo
they mad
give them more it wasn't that it wasn't
that
that's when flawless steps to the fire
to the flame like putting on another
tick-tock video and just gas in
everybody
exactly so it's one of those situations
like look we're locked in
this is something that has been planned
and mapped out
so now we're seeing the feedback while
we're giving this new
this new stuff they don't like it in pvp
at all and yeah this now the second part
is gonna be my guess
my guess which shouldn't be too far off
i feel is that
you gotta look at those they're data
driven they got to look at those
population numbers
they got to look at what's going on and
in pvp
it's not popping so i think what
happened internally is they say look
we got so many resources we could do we
got new content new seasons this which
which queen's delayed whatever whatever
we want to give them pvp maps
but let's fix this stasis thing first
because this is what they're screaming
about the most
and then let's see what's going on now
to your final question which is actually
the question
which is how i feel about the weapon and
to me this is idealistic stuff like this
is how it should be right weapons should
be
primary focus it shouldn't be so much
about ability
you know i'm i'm dying to know how
they're going to they say abilities have
clear strengths weak weakness and
counter play i really want to hear more
about the kind of play that is very
funny to me
i want to know what this counter play is
for abilities but
that's neither here nor there but
ideally these statements
are what it should be about the gameplay
and gun play excuse me as opposed to
ability spam and last point i'll say is
i think they tried this at the start of
d2
remember d2 cooldowns were low it took
us a while to get their super
and stuff like that the problem was
it was the double primary meta yeah
which everybody er and it was the
i love that by the way oh see me ally
you have to kick you off the shoulder
i hated that man hey like and remember
it was
also the non-random role
yeah remember that was whack yes
super whack that was so dumb
yeah because that was when they were
going so bad and it was so
unfun so yeah daddy i think they just
got to get
right in that middle right but we got
now we have our random rolls
we're out of that double primary stuff
right but
i agree abilities do need to reign back
in a little bit it's just
it's no skill when you just throw in
ability after ability after bill you
didn't even shoot your gun
and you know i i i can understand
frustration but that's what i had to say
that's what i thought about it
alan which way you at with that
statement about primary gun play
and about you know strength weakness and
more about moment-to-moment
combat yeah i'll put money on it
that the majority of uh destiny audience
love destiny purely because of the gun
play
because it's perfect the gun play is
just
chev's kiss it's so clean but the
problem is now
uh no has become like this they don't
have the opportunity
to use it anymore yeah they don't know
where to use it anymore
because why would i put effort into
getting a kill
when i can throw something with a click
of a button that can kill like 10 things
at the same time
what is the point yeah i mean those are
big win buttons
oh yeah yeah like it's it and then
i posted a clip the other day i just my
first time playing stasis because you
know integrity and stuff
uh things that don't matter i played
with stasis the first time after
what is it that the new aspect that they
dropped the winter whatever
yeah i threw a cold snap it literally
froze the entire theme
and i didn't even aim it and through it
and i didn't put the clip on late and i
was like yeah this is fine yes
yo e i gotta ask you this did you see
fallout's video on this oh my god
did you see the thumbnail uh i haven't
seen the video yet all right alex
thumbnails great
the clip in the video yes but he was a
warlock somebody
he would say was a warlock in trials
wherever it was
froze someone solid for six
times oh the looping was yeah i saw that
joey yes
yeah fall out clip that yeah because
i've never seen that oh he just like
froze
froze super froze super froze rift like
and the dude was just stuck there and i
was like oh that's awful
you want to hear something funny about
that though let's go before
joe waited put that out right when stacy
was first released
calico and a couple other boys
recorded that and they put the exact
same version without a super
oh no without a super literally with
riffs
shade stepping close to them throwing uh
what is it those uh shurikens
they didn't touch the gate at all they
did not that's
the the shurikens weren't even aimed at
just simply thrown somewhere and they
were just
doing that and they put and put this up
saying that this is okay and everybody
just passed it off laughing at it and
stuff but they're pointing out this is
too strong and nobody takes them
seriously and then it becomes really
really strong
and everybody complains about it it's
and
that's i don't know what i i don't know
i don't know what they were thinking
when they
started releasing these fragments some
of these fragments are
broken beyond repair yeah like this
season especially
like all of them seem to be doing
something the let's make
your hunter grenades even stronger than
they already were
with like i'm like are you serious like
maybe put that on the back burner or i
don't know like this is again the same
thing they have this road map stuff
planned out but
then when you say hey here's this thing
like these things are already crazy
powerful
people aren't a huge fan at least the
vocal minority is not a huge fan and
then you turn around and make this stuff
even stronger it's like again
this is where they need have all the
crazy photostasis you want pvp pve
make those grenades broken let them
catch like people out of the air do what
you got like
but again in pvp and they're talking
about it like that's the part where if
there's new stasis stuff coming out
they got to make sure and pull way back
on the reins
for the pvp side even before it launches
then if you can be like
yeah this one isn't doing that much then
you could be like hey we feel like this
one's not actually getting a lot of use
or anything like that then you can mess
with it but don't start huge
like that's the way things are right now
it just was it's it's not tone deaf
because they're not but it's like the
development roadmap and then testing and
everything they have it working so they
want to get it out there
but then you're like what have you done
why why is it even stronger than ever
like that was the weird thing about this
it was stronger than it ever was
honestly bro it's weird i think they
need to
this is personally i think this is what
they need to do they need to pick
game breaking players that do this on a
consistent basis from pve
and pvp cheese forever yeah three from
easy forever
each place they did they just have to
pick them
and ask them to play test every sandbox
change
right yeah i mean every day one hour i'm
sure our boys will give it to them no
oh yeah no you asked them and they would
probably do it for them you know
and it's it's an honor like that's
bungee and you know
i'm sure they'll do it and you know if
it comes to money might probably even
pay them
who knows i was like yeah small indiana
contract or something for testing but
yeah
our boys brains no our people's brains
is wired weird
they're they're they're brilliant when
it comes to breaking the game
on all cylinders but when you're a
developer and you're creating something
you're looking at the beauty of it you
know they're so
they're so taken back with what they've
created because this is their baby no
like this
this is something that's special to them
and obviously
you have a baby what happens you don't
want to be like uh this baby's nose is
that
great you know you're not gonna say all
that you know just take care
you're gonna be like oh this is the
cutest thing ever you know it's
beautiful you know whatever look they
already bought after the baby clothes
the bastard
and yeah oh they're just ready for a
baby yeah
and what happened is you gonna get this
baby and then
once we finally get time we're now
they're like now we're going to give it
some extra care the things we were
supposed to do
because there's some things y'all don't
like about it
yeah this is what it is yeah i was like
but that's kind of one of those weird
things is you're like this is the
development cycle we're in versus the
community screaming on the other side
like
stasis is really powerful like
somebody somewhere has to be like uh
are we are we gonna release this
and it's like and then let's like and
you know they know when somebody's like
we're this far in this is like this is
where we're at we have to roll with it
and maybe honestly like the feedback and
stuff the like the jump for the speed
of this patch is massive for them to
bring it so it's like
that's what i'm saying yeah it's like
they're doing it doing it within the
time constraints that they have with the
development like
course that they're already on and this
is one of those weird ones now the
question is
i mean if you get to a witch queen and
we have a poison subclass with dots and
like death over time things and you get
to
another subclass possibly in which queen
do we go
down this road all over again oh like
yes so that's what i'm saying bro
i was like and then it's like is this
just this is just gonna be the cycle and
you
may as well just strap into the roller
coaster and go for the ride we've been
doing this since when the destination oh
i know
yeah it's like it's it's every time
yeah so that's kind of the thing to like
get to everybody is
you know gunplay is going to be their
abilities are going to be strong we get
new things these are fun to play with
and they got to reign them back in
here's the new exotic it's too strong we
got to reign it back in
and we go on these waves all the time
yep all the time it always they
think about this abilities
weapon sandbox buffs to the meta
always come in hot always at the
beginning
oh we like oh my god they letting us do
this oh my god lament
oh my god discharged with light bill oh
my god wore my cells
it's stasis it it always debuts
hot remember when when taken king
sun breakers you heard the crank oh yeah
i was one of those guys
no no it's not no you no no when
somebody pops a hammer no
you hear the thing and you're like it's
just an amber but somebody pops the the
do you hear like that
remember yeah you're terrible
but that's with every stasis super now
you just run yeah yeah
what can i do against like honestly like
you freaking warlocks out there just
like bring
bling yeah i'm like there's nothing you
can do to a warlock super like
nothing the most broken class
is the thank you glass thank
it's not even the super i don't even
care about the super the super is broken
let's not even talk about that
actually that's stupid cryo classic i'm
a titan man by the way i love my titan
that's stupid chronicles
slade it has immunity frames yes
what the hell like like when he when
they turn their slide back to back
that entire frame has immunity frames
like you cannot shoot them like
how am i supposed to kill you bro like
you keep sliding back and forth
and i don't think they nerfed it by the
way the removing cooldown i think it's a
bad idea
1.25 second sprint you remember they
made this happen for another exotic too
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is okay think about it like this
1.25 seconds between another before
another slate
you run and if you slayed you know
between the the uh what is it you slate
and as soon as you you you get up one
second two points
you it's the same thing but you can
repeat it now without the cooldown
before the cooldown was you had to wait
for eight seconds no six seconds
and then you slayed now you're only
waiting like 1.25 seconds and just
all you have to do is sprint titans
never walk
there are some characters and i feel
like it's like you know this
the dash is like on their scroll wheel
or whatever there's certain like
keys that people have said because that
people just like slide slides
and it's not even just titans i see this
in like some classes just like
sliding everywhere just to move around
i'm like
there's definitely something i'm missing
for sure or i haven't dug into like
mobility enough and that's on me for
sure
but you're talking about these sweat
sweat players who play screws all the
time who do nothing but slay
bunny hop slade bunny hop
titan slate the credit closing slate is
so broken anybody can do it
yeah like literally that's all that's
all they have to do
i'm a titan man bro i don't like it
because it's so it's free
if you put on i promise you yeah but our
answer is
slide your heart out you can literally
muzzle everybody
in the map like nothing can touch you
the only death is gonna be
if when when you slayed and they
accidentally shoot you with the
weapon in one in one of your immunity
frames and you know obviously
the face has this you know the artifact
that bug where the misadventure kills
you
that's the only way you're gonna die
because yeah
it's broken criticalism is broken that
it's
it's amazing because it makes the titan
feel so late you know i love it
at the same same time i can acknowledge
this is not supposed to be in the game
however if they're going to take the cry
classroom away i want my spot like
garrison back so i can compete with
other classes
yeah we do feel kind of glued to the
ground sometimes but yeah
i want my solid yeah so classes each got
their pieces but
stasis freeze reduced the duration of
all non-super
freezes versus players to 1.35 seconds
uh it's too short to break out of so
basically you're just gonna be in it
before you can break out of it so it's
just almost enough to stagger you
reduce special weapon heavy weapon and
light
ability bonus damage versus frozen
players from 50
to 5 so basically it's non-existent for
any bonus damage against frozen players
that you've got now
the slow no longer reduces weapon
accuracy shout out to the entire fire
range crew i know they're already happy
about that
i hear about that all the time all the
time
no longer the damage bonus you know why
they did that
is because of the new exotic leg armors
oh
probably true stacks with the weapon
damage boost it stacks with the
the slow uh when you get slowed you get
an additional boost
for your weapon and you can stack it up
on top of that you can keep stacking it
and get one shot at kills it's
crazy yeah for the slows
no longer suppresses class abilities and
air moves
i.e icarus dash though and then reduced
movement speed penalty while slowed so
you're 20
faster while you're slow so you're not
quite as not quite as cement shoes on
the ground
um they also said the cold snap grenade
seeker
no longer tracks targets after initial
target acquisition huge
increased aiming arming duration before
seeker spawns from point three to point
eight
reduces detonation radius versus players
from three meters to one and a half so
that got half
half as big but they did say it now
bounces off walls and detonates on the
ground so you you can actually
bank it around a corner now which may be
a bad thing but
i have to see what that does but that's
got some changes and you've got subclass
changes we don't have to go through
everything on them uh i'm in the glacial
quake you got a little bit more damage
reduction
um trying to see if there's any big ones
shiver straight
yeah yeah reduced flight speed and
distance that's a big one because people
are just like
flying around the map reduce knock back
versus players you're not going to knock
them as far and you remove the slow
detonation on player impact
part of me is like that's a lot for the
melee like that thing just got hit
real hard i mean i know some people are
like like kill it down but it's like
i don't know if it's actually going to
completely not but
it deserves it okay every no mercy on
any stasis class yo
everything is broken it's just like kill
it all kill it all he'll kill it all
like i have no problem
the only thing that that should freeze
you is the super itself
nothing else should freeze you uh yeah
that's what that that's literally what
they're doing that's literally what
they're doing it literally
the freeze effect is uh is it it's it's
all restricted to the super now
yeah and then it if they bring you to a
point
where only the super freezes you you'll
see that people start using other
subclasses
they'll start trying out new things
they'll stop focusing only on stasis and
all these
you know things that just freeze you
like
but bunji wants you to spend a lot of
time in this game but they also
make you lazy as hell
you definitely people definitely crutch
on certain abilities yeah and then and
and i'm i'm not i'm not a fan of any of
that like i
i want to fight against different
different names every time you know i
want to play against different different
players
you know and i feel like that's so we
get to know each other like we play
the same players over and over again
it's becoming like this
hate back and forth this guy i keep
playing him all the time it's so
irritating like
what is this and stuff like that that's
that's how it's going now you know
because nobody wants to play
crucible anymore everybody's getting
irritated and that's why this patch
got pushed up yep just which is that's
why
uh so then hunters withering blade got a
lot of things so you reduce the slow
duration versus players
uh from two and a half to one and a half
seconds to reduce the whisper of
durant's slow duration extension
from two to point five seconds uh reduce
damage versus players from
65 to 45 and after one bounce it's down
to 30.
uh reduce projectile speed by 10 percent
reduce tracking off of walls so the
withering blade is that the
kunai basically the throwing kunai yeah
yeah those those are definitely getting
a hit
similar to and people were just but
people were blind throwing them so again
they're taking they took a lot of the
skill
out of those and they're trying to reel
them back in so if you are gonna get hit
by a withering blade hopefully it does
take a bit more
intentional choice than you used to
actually get something out of it and
guess what you got to aim just like
well one last two we're going to gotta
eat use the controller
so then finally for warlocks you got the
penumbral blast reduces tracking and
proximity detonation
size and tracking versus players reduced
freeze radius versus players when
impacting the environment from
2.7 to 1.5 your ice flare bolts seeker
now only chains
once wind spawned from player shatter on
the winter's wrath
freezing projectiles tracking strength
now ramps down to zero
after two seconds of flight yeah
yeah i mean look that was beefy though
that this straw was beefy like
it's unexpected i i love all of it
i'm yet to uh i still need to test a few
of those things we do this when we
gather together like in the mornings
with the boys and we just test out all
this stuff
bruh day one that grenade launcher the
slideshow grenade launcher ignition code
yeah ignition minute we got it we
tweeted about it and i
i told him this is gonna be broken as
well because this is insta
this is not supposed to be a thing you
can
you can slide through slide shoes that
shouldn't be a thing
you can keep spamming it and
then that doesn't belong in crucible
like
how how did it yeah who thought of this
like yeah who was that i know look like
i said for me this
is the community rose up against this
for a long time they've been better and
i think this is an example of them
changing their bit of their role mapping
their development cycle
to focus on this and if that's the
reason
for why the map and the pvp focus has
been
non-mentioned then i can deal with that
because i
short term because i i feel that yeah
sure i'm still gonna be on them
about it but if this which appears to be
why i mean i've never seen they were
like yo they're supposed to come next
season you getting this next thursday
nothing is not nothing is coming from
pvp next season i think that's why they
give this
honestly it's probably not yeah i mean
it's like it's seasonal content i don't
expect it it's seasonal so look at the
end of the day
i i'm curious to you know people got
popping bottles they rejoice it i get it
i want to see it in action
the feeling seems to be just like that
you know i i
want to see it out there and i think
that's the start
to getting people to want to at least
get
back in there participate yes yeah
because
right because to me for them to push
this up i'm not going to
keep re-emphasizing let me emphasize it
that means
dumb numbers that bottom line was
affected on that pvp
and that's what i always tell people
like they're they're very
data driven they're very analytic
engagement driven
usage they're telling you the usage
rates this is the highest
you know what you call the hunters are
the third highest of all selected and
like they're giving you that's the way
they operate
so to me that tells me they finally
got hit and they're like there's
something you don't get hit right
they like if we don't do something right
this is gonna go worse
right
in a way it's a good thing because it's
like yo we're not gonna play until you
address
now the second thing which i will give
them a pass again
stasis is one if they could somehow
get a hold of this anti-cheat all right
and
somehow clean that up on the pvp side
fix your face out i know it i know it's
a it's a dream i know it's a dream but
let me have this so
at the end of the day right if they
could somehow
integrate that and get back to more
clean
play right less aim body less
that is now you talk about you it's
almost like you clean the house first
before you make it an addition
you got to clean this whole house you
got to scrub it down
bro you could get there we could get
there you know what sad bro
really really good players that you know
that i play against on a regular basis
really really good players i've noticed
that they started using
walls to counter players now because
they don't know who they're playing
against
oh yeah they don't know if they're
playing against feeders or not
and they're being pushed to a point
where they have to use balls
they either do it legally or illegally
right yeah
and and that's sad no that's really sad
no
it's like you can notice when you're
playing against the team certain moves
they make
is so like it's so it's such a
dead giveaway like nobody's gonna
you know be there because there's no
radar ping but you're still
coming and finding me there you know and
then when you notice things like that
constantly not one of case like
constantly really really good players
doing it
and that's when you want to stay away
from you know i don't want this because
this is not healthy
because i don't want to get to a point
and call out somebody
because i don't know for sure either
right okay and it puts you in this
suspicious
uh yeah yeah i'll get you get your
mindset
and um people that and
and that that causes a lot of problems
like within the community too let's say
creators play
play against creators right and people
call each other out and this
just causes so much nonsense like
it's unwanted heat you know
we're already fickle when it comes to
like handling ourselves
as individuals or whatever when it comes
to the game
not like irl i mean irl everybody's a g
they're in their own rate but when it
comes to the game everybody you know
they have their
knots twisted or in some way the other
they're like oh i'm right you're right
my club is bigger your clothes bigger
but who cares this is a video game to
load
you know i don't like those feelings i
like that
i like that people are coming back and
participating and
and and they're receiving the spacious
things and stuff
i want the same energy to keep going for
the next few seasons right now like i
can't
absolutely look i can't i got like
two months from now vaulted glass is not
gonna cut it
of course it's not what's that it's not
gonna cut it right and
obviously we can bank on our nostalgia
or whatever to
so once the vex with the class hits like
a lot of people are not going to be
interested in doing vlog anymore
you know and it's it's gonna it's not
gonna be a thing and then the only thing
to fall back on going to be pvp right
right and if anthony doesn't hit
right and if stasis is not reeled in
right that's that's why we're here where
we at
and stasis cheat second then to me to me
season is season of the cleansing isn't
it yeah
these are the cleansing of season 15.
you do the stasis you do the anti-cheat
and then you can smoothly hopefully
integrate
crossplay which would be a boom a big
shot
will be back next yeah that will be big
there's so many
communities including my own where you
know we're split apart
and stuff like that i was sad like he's
like damn he ain't got a rape team i'm
like man if it was here
oh i know we could get it will be able
to play wherever
you want so that'll be great did you
guys get to jump into
cross play strike playlist do you guys
jump in at all
one i broke the cross play when it
launched before it launched
uh well i mean this week when it was
supposed to be there
not previously i know you guys did that
yeah but i was gonna say did you guys
get a chance
did you get like for me honestly it felt
like it felt
completely uneventful which i think was
a good thing
yeah it was like it was just like zero
lag zero major issues just was
it just happened and i was like if now
it's like from hearing what people went
through on stuff like outriders for
example
cross play if you got two or three
people i knew a new rad and black wings
and chat
it was just like it was bad people were
dropping it was really laggy like
unplayable and if i can jump into a
strike and cross play and it feels
effortless like and i was on pc i did i
couldn't see
who i was if i crossed like different
platforms i couldn't tell
it wouldn't show but if it was that
clean
then i was that's what i'm looking
forward to because then it's like
you know if like i'm asking for people
hey do you guys want to play or any
streamer content creators just like
crossboy cannot get here soon enough
because you're looking for like carries
for raid
hey anybody doesn't matter what platform
you're on come on now i may be waiting
on the spinning hard drive
lg ps4 and xbox one guys
you you non-nvme dudes yeah upgrade your
hard drive
come on guys i gotta be really
tight with you for me to be rocking with
you with that situation
yeah so i was like but that's kind of
the nice things
the crossplay part like the opting in
for the pc for pvp
all of that will be very very cool um
and it just it felt good to jump in and
literally have it
i was like okay i might i was like i had
to check i'm like am i in the right
playlist
because i don't feel anything and that's
i think all you can ask for i mean
cod does it you know you got um warzone
and you've got other things that are
doing it right now fortnite fortnite
apex
you've got some big ones and then you
know as long as sony can play nice and
get their head out of their butts
everybody will be on a really good page
because
i think if it feels that good in a raid
there's no lag there's no major issues
with encounters gambit distiller is
broken
i'm like please don't give us any more
moats to pick up because i'm still
running over it
it like falls through my body i'll run
by i'll turn around it's still sitting
back there on the ground
and it's like and i know they have this
the weird like lag net code like 20
people can't pick up the same mote
i get that but i'm like it doesn't feel
good so please don't make that like in
the future encounters all i'm asking
like for the first crossplay raid
don't make it that um but other than
that like i was very
happy to see crossplay was just honestly
painless it was like ultra painless and
it's just something to look forward to
overall so
that doesn't have to be a big discussion
i just wanted to shout that out that it
was
it was butter smooth i got my emblem and
i was like cool if it's that smooth then
bring it on now but
the other thing that launched on tuesday
was expunge
and i wanted to see if you guys had a
chance to jump in and play if you guys
they'd even looked at like the images or
anything
yeah that's that that that was bungie's
way of shouting out astro cross that the
whole thing was asked across his
advertisement the mission
have y'all played it
yeah it's like any any retro situation
is gonna look like yeah
but i was like i know i don't think
cognito's played it but did you play it
yeah i was like what do you think yeah
yeah right okay which i think which i
was going on
it was it was dope you know i like
platforming missions in general
yeah because i think platform yeah
this is just me being petty because i'm
a bad jumping warlock
so you just put the fear god in me when
you said
jumps all over the place and i'm like oh
yeah there's there's a few of them
they're all that's like the whole
opening now
granted i got to a point where i did the
whole thing in like seven and a half
minutes so i was like you can get to a
point where it's fairly efficient you
can skip a lot of the guys
but you still got to be able to jump to
do that jump
up ascending or descending
i would say it's mostly descending
honestly
it's not as much i would say it is a
gibberish
it's both gang let's go i would say it
is generally a downhill
like most of it is going to be even if
it's like varying degrees of like big
drops and small drops i would say a lot
of it is a
it's like the buzz lightyear falling in
style like you need to catch the falls
you need to get the right points and
if you're going fast you got to be
moving there's very few very few places
you got to go up and if you do it's not
as
precise i would say so harry potter's
yeah you can marry poppins your way
through this whole thing you can floof
your uh
flip it all the way through um but
when it comes to the calendar this thing
was called the weekly
pinnacle mission had a bit of a
communication problem there i'm gonna
say
um do you guys know what i'm talking
about
um so basically what happened is the
weekly pinnacle mission
did not drop pinnacles first off didn't
really have any specific rewards listed
to it that were like obvious on your
first cleared no weekly challenges
they did clarify for the first four
weeks of the new expunge mission players
should expect to earn a piece of high
stat seasonal armor
in addition to some decrypted data for
their first time through each mission
once players have earned their high stat
armor set by completing their first four
missions remaining weekly expunge
missions
upon first completion will reward a
seasonal
weapon with additional perk choices in
the final column instead of an
additional armor piece
starting in suit on june 15th a new
pinnacle activity challenge will roll
out connected to the expunge missions
providing an additional pinnacle rewards
source each week for the remainder of
the season this coincides with an
additional layer of replayability by
introducing the expunged missions like i
get
this the only thing about it for me was
just the fact that it was like
poorly communicated again it's the
expectation setting of weekly pinnacle
mission like
if you're gonna call it a weekly
pinnacle mission and then it's not an
actual
pinnacle mission that's kind of an issue
yeah so it's like mine was the
communication i didn't know if you guys
like cared about this nothing at all it
was like
i don't even care as much about the
pinhole the pinnacle grind is a whole
weird thing right now because it's
not there but the fact that like hey
this is going to be where you're going
to get your high stats seasonal drops
then we're going to be giving you double
rolled weapons uh the other part of the
splicer gauntlet is going to do some
unlocks here later on but right now
just just go play it because yeah like
it's
just not clear why so it's just kind of
one of those things for me it's like
just little
when there's again this is the whole
like kg on some things or forget about
some patch notes and otherwise they'll
tell you be like hey this is you know
going to be covering all this stuff so
it's just a weird thing i enjoyed the
mission
very cool first time i went through like
25 minutes took a couple screenshots
figuring out the platforming unlocking
your splicer gauntlet is a win
get that whole left column completely
unlocked you will be happy you did
um because the first one is going to
unlock like the little green platforms
you unlock in override
yes yes those are helpful so those are
definitely beneficial the second one is
more
gravity cannons which i think are
possibly the ones around the boss arena
which is going to be a good thing
and then the third one actually opens
like a shortcut like straight away in
the beginning and i don't know if
there's another one
but those three will make your speed
runs faster because there's challenges
to do
specifically this week's in less than 10
minutes okay
so it's doable honestly like you know
you can eat the boss with the titan
super or some big
super especially with you know like
breach and clear hit him with the super
he nearly died that fast but i was like
i get him killed i even killed him with
the rockets
so if you got the super you did it
faster but it's just i enjoyed the
mission going through it but i was
curious you guys thoughts for one on the
mission but two also the communication
so overall
i think bungie is getting lazy with the
names the boss's name is
fantas like why we gotta disrespect the
names
why didn't god get to work no like
fantastic he's disgusting
don't you wanna fantasy yeah
yeah that's what like i'm like wha
what's the name what's the next one
chipotles
like no bruh
also i'm not happy with this uh season
uh i'll tell you why
because there's literally nothing
there's literally nothing to do
uh new right there's a new six-man
activity which we've done like a bunch
of times and
yeah i've beat my head through that
enough yeah and
uh walter glass is an old raid that they
just you know gave
to us in 4k it's the only season where
the loot is amazing
but it's the same things that i have to
do again and again to get it
right yeah and it's annoying welcome to
the seasonal model sir
yeah they get
like the loot the guns with frenzy
heating up there's some perks people
really love and the guns are feeling
good
exotics are kind of spicy if not a
little too spicy
but yeah if you look at the road map
you're like override which is gambit
just pve it is now the vex network side
i do enjoy
granted the boss fights are nothing too
crazy some of the teleports it's fine
but again
when you start like at some point you're
gonna want to grind out
the gauntlet to be able to do that no
matter whether you grind it in the first
week like some of us crazy people or you
play it a little bit
it is still override for the number of
times that you need
to get it done and if you just do the
math on that thing
that is a lot of one thing and that's
the only place you get it from expunge
you get once a week except you get a
little once a week
but you're going to be spending if you
want to finish the gauntlet which is
beneficial if you want to finish the
gauntlet there's
one thing you can do you can't get the
decrypted data anywhere else you can't
like you know
if you do a chat like if you did your
weekly challenges you could get some
decrypted data from that
just have other ways to get it so i'm
not just like two strikes override
two game of matches override oh by the
way side note i'm not touching gambit
until basically every challenge is open
so when i do finally jump into gambit i
can actually check all the boxes i'm not
starting on week one
hey play some gambit week three come
back and play some gambit because this
isn't retroactive
i am not doing that again i am not
touching gambit until it is like
completely open on the challenge list so
like even this week i'm like okay fine
but it's
i'm with you it's like you do that and
you look you got iron banner on there
like four times if iron banner is
plastered on the calendar
right not generally a good thing
better yeah that shotgun is the only
reason i played four
and i can't even get that shotgun what
the hell oh yeah and then iron banner
broken so
you can't get look people spend hundreds
and hundreds of tokens and then finally
they're like oh it's not working right
now
yeah they've been having pickle and drop
issues these things for sure
yeah pinnacle's not quite working some
of that stuff got fixed so the hot fix
coming is going to be fixing some of
that stuff but again as you said
the weekly pinnacle mission was like
cool i played it like three times
basically you know did it fast enough
for the sub 10 minutes and then i'll do
that a couple times in the next couple
weeks but
as you said like vog is going to have a
short shelf life for some
sherpas are going to have sherpas are
going to have fun with a new raid
because it is somewhat fresh and the
grand masters will kick off a little bit
later
but as you said for new content like
expunge is
you know we probably get this week and
next week of labyrinth and then we get a
couple two other we i think there's a
couple of the rotations because there's
two listed
two other ones we haven't seen but yeah
it's like if you go beat you know the
expunge mission
three times in a week and then it as you
said there isn't a ton
there but the loot is fairly cool so
the loot is amazing the boot is esteer
lulu zestier i won't even argue with
that
no but there's literally nothing fun to
do there's
it's not if anybody tells you doing
overweight more than five times is fun
they're maniacs i'm sorry like this this
is boring
it has to if you're going with with them
you know
with with family with your friends or
whatever like going in a six-man team
talking trash or whatever yeah you can
pass your time that's not because the
activity is good it's because you're
you're with good company and you know
you can you can push through it
i think how how do you do this like over
and over again and accept this as new
content like
i i can't like and
vlog isn't all right like where is my
pve stuff like
like sponge mission like it's cool
you know i'll do it five times once i
hit my pinnacle cap why do i want to do
this
like you know like this is pointless
like and
there's no specif specific loot that
comes off of it either
i get it and then everything you know
your your frustration with it
valid i i can understand it i think not
without compassion bro i understand
everything that they're going through
and everything that's happening of
course still allowed to
be frustrated i'm still allowed to vent
and
let them know like it sucks terrible
no i feel you i think like i said
everything you said is valid i think my
my frustration is different um
i think with override
maybe it's just me i i like the concept
of it but i feel like shout out to cars
going by
but i feel like it's not challenging
enough
no like i feel it's like like i was
playing and like
dudes didn't even know what to go up to
the top and do the little
things and i'm like okay cool and then
it's like
i don't feel there's enough enemy
density to like they need a
hard mode like it's just not i feel like
it i could just go in there and do what
i want
and i was i was sitting there working on
like a pulse rifle triumph and it was
like i wasn't looking at any big guys
like every little
every little guy i'm just gonna work on
the little guys you guys take care of
the rest and that's all
all i did yeah shout out to the real
durant it's
it's not enough see they just came off
of battlegrounds
where i was loving the enemy density
right it was
already for the front if in the back
even though we did a lot of damn
battlegrounds right
but at least the activity to me was more
exciting and there was a little bit of a
challenge to it sometimes right
this i feel like i get it because six
man the blueberry squad i feel you type
but the thing is it's like
they're gonna need a harder mode like
this
the mechanics and what they're trying to
implement even when you go down the
slide you could
literally the first two dudes can make
it you don't even have to do the whole
no
if you're going for the flawless don't
jump just let of the joke yeah just if
you're trying to do your flawless runs
stay in the back pick off people because
it's patrol zones so you can get pretty
far away
let anybody do the jumping puzzle and
then say by the little like rotating
thing in the front and shoot thing
you don't even have to move in that
thing and you can get flawless like
and then even the boss when you get
there it's just not enough
and there's no i i don't ever feel like
i'm in danger in that mode
no ever gambit would you say
what did you say by yourself
through the blueberry you have to do all
that it's fun
listen man you know teach his own for me
oh okay yeah about my frustration is
it's just that you know the act i love
six man activities
they say sundown you know saying this
ain't the same oh
yeah it's like yeah there were champions
there were champions in there
yeah another reason why i love
battlegrounds so much
lore yes this this lord with mythrax
running it
the best part i i think was me a section
where i didn't run it and i went up to
the terminal i go for this was the
hottest thing i thought
as far as law wise when the terminal
has lakshivi and she's like listen they
tell her you know this is a democracy
akora did put these slimy falling in
here
she said did they ask you did they did
did they get your word
a lunch man yo she with it she is like
she's cheating bro yo i love that was
she's about to like cause some drama in
the tower
she's like oh this is democracy huh did
you ask for the fallen to be in here
she was like i'm telling you we can't
trust him like she was in her back she's
creating her little propaganda whatever
but it's good like that to me was the
best
part of the lord because because
in the activity methox is boring me i'm
just like all right okay come on you're
all right
all right guardian go you now vex do the
vex network and do this and i'm just
like
i'm not there with it but but yo like
shiva yo like
i want to see where that go that that's
literally why i'm hanging in
all right rolex she was more like whack
she died man she she get
her she get her separatism on she shot
him
yeah she is she's the doomsdayer for
sure
she i mean she she's becoming that quote
unquote
character that people are gonna hate and
yeah he's gonna be the characters
the same titan there's the stealth
that's telling you that's my brother
by the way that was talking [ __ ] about
uh
the crow yeah you know and then and no
you know crow
i'm
not get over the fact that they killed
my boy k-6 bro
they killed my boy
yeah isn't that still one of the best
expansions to destiny 2 though because
of that catalyst
yeah and then now you have the arc of
him versus the crow like they
that was a big catalyst for the destiny
2 story i'm i'm hoping the whole crow
stuff pays off but
it was still one of the longer pieces
there is no character like that anymore
like literally
no no character can carry like kate cat
i mean no other character
i hate zavala man he's not even worthy
of being a vanguard
i hate that guy if you if okay if
something
[ __ ] happens to something happens to him
right would you be like oh
for the good of the world i'm not going
to go away shut up
shut up i think i don't want to see
lance riddick go i don't want to see
last reticle
i don't care for zavala but i
love how much lance puts into the role
oh yeah
yeah the way he communicates with the
community too you can see like he yeah
there's no redeeming qualities about
zavala at all none
it's
it's a lot it's hard to argue a lot a
lot of people ain't feeling them you
know i'm saying i get that you know
so said sure i wrote i like sure he
loose
yeah like look man i i'm just curious to
see what i go
as far as the fall and stuff like that
just the advancement but
for right now i will give you all this
like yeah after playing
a few i've even played a lot of them i
put a few alright
and i sat there and i'm like what is it
about it's just like connecting with me
and i
it is that it's the it's the challenge
it's the lack of uh density and then
like you said e the fact that you got to
run that specific activity
only that's your only major way to get
those
materials but it's also bug you if you
focus on engrams
uh like uh if you have like let's say
you have 500 of those data thingies
right
and you first it takes double well it
should have been fixed i think they did
actually try and fix that
still that way oh i know that's one
thing okay yeah they were supposed
to or at least it's in the works to be
fixed so yeah that's why i haven't
focused in
grandma season because of that yeah
because it's the currency and that's the
thing
it's like currency to do that i put 70 i
put everything in the vault
i put 75 in the character the group did
put 75 more
the group didn't oh yeah you make it you
make it only take the normal amount yeah
you force it out of it
this season yeah it's like it's it's
again like
you know a step forward step back for
the season it's like the setup of the
fallen is cool but
again you know as you said the the
discussions at the end of override i do
it so much i'm tuning it out
i was like i was like i'm just and it's
it's not quite hitting the same way the
stuff in the tower each week is pretty
cool like
getting the voicemail hearing from myth
racks seeing like the
because what who were sitting in the uh
was it osiris
mythrax and who was actually sitting in
the hangar or in the helm
oh and i i know saint pulled up one time
and saint wasn't feeling him of course
yeah so it's like we've had some those
are cool interactions i love those story
beats
the voiceovers like you hear them but
then you start hearing some of the same
ones over and over and there hasn't been
a lot of
variants there either but yeah it's like
expunge while a cool mission to go
through
once and then i was like cool i can you
know work on the timer and i did it a
couple of times to try and get a good
run for a video
but you have zero incentive to play that
thing more than once a week
unless you're just a triumph hunter like
you play through it once a week you
might get your you know
whether it's going to be the armor of
the first four weeks or the weapon with
two roles later on
it's a cool mission and unfortunately
there's not as much
reason there's not even an exotic or a
pinnacle drop in there right now
so it's just in a weird it's a weird
state and again we have weeks of just
that's the only thing on the calendar
besides iron banner every so often like
that is it for the next like seven weeks
six
yeah yeah and they're so sad that is so
sad and then we get salsas all over
again
think uh what is it called um actually
even
since you brought up trans right i i was
one of those kids that
that loved chasing triumphs and titles
right yeah
i was always on perfect until last two
just the last two seasons i just didn't
do anything reason is
they keep taking away the exclusivity of
the titles and the
triumphs they just at a certain point we
had to do flawless to
attain a title right and then the next
season you know
they told you don't have to do flawless
anymore you can get the title
you know gambit you know we farm for
four days straight to get the
meatball to spawn and we got it done and
we
got the dredges every week i'm the og
dredjan
you know they got the dredging and then
and then like
two months two months later they took
away the exclusivity of that title and
they just gave it to everybody
they keep doing this over and over again
and like
what's the point i don't want to flick
some triumph score
when i don't feel exclusive about it now
every everything is so accessible to
everybody like
i want it to be accessible but i wanted
to be difficult to acquire
you gotta have that balance you still
gotta yeah yeah where there's still
things that the hardcore can achieve
that they can flex and only they can do
and
no you're making a good point there i
mean that that's always going to be the
balance for them it's always going to be
that because
again when you're successful and you're
making money and the engagement is high
it's harder to listen because they doing
well
right but when the numbers go down and
things start to shift
then you're going to get more of a
change so that's just where we're at
right now i mean look
you know like i always say you know like
you've always said you know i mean
once you get in you do what you got to
do you know we'll see how this season
continues
and if not there's other games out here
so there's no need to be angry crazy
yo pulling up on bungie's offices with
the picket fences like that you know
what i'm saying
what's there and that's kind of why i'm
i'm with you it's like this you look at
the calendar
you're like oh people were excited about
vog we got it early expunge
we got an idea what it looks like now i
kind of figured it was the vex network
pretty much straight up that
uh it's cool and don't get me wrong i
love the aesthetic
like the design of the mission the
platforming is fun
the challenge to run it fast isn't bad
but then it's like
the yeah i was like i still got mass
effect so that's all
yes he's still got mass effect get only
aware
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
fun stuff coming up
on games coming out that's why i'm not
too worried about this season
yeah and that's honestly it's going to
be nice
yeah this this is going to be like you
know that season where you go to the
beach
but you don't jump in the you just like
dip your
what i always say is this like i how i
maintain myself
through it and not stress is i have my
little internal goals i'm like okay cool
i want to get a freight bringer
with the kind of road that i want if i
can get vex
great i still haven't got the what is it
grid skipper with a good roll
ignition coat like there's certain
little modes i mean about weapons and
builds that i want
and obviously artifacts and all that
other stuff and that's it i i i got my
my uh law sector done i got the warlock
boots i'm
feeling those warlock boots with
aluminum yeah
so not like the true support build like
just said
thank shout out to you don't matter to
set your own
personal goals focus on that once you
got what you got to get you got the bag
there's a lot of games out here chill it
ain't going away i will be there
thursday though
because i want to see
cause stasis got beat up jumped in the
corner
bad stasis bad stuff so i can't wait
so that that like i get i got my little
milestones
each season that i look forward to
during the season and that's it just
chill
ain't no need to go crazy and and you
know whatever lose your mind it's it's
tons of stuff out here i got mass effect
to be
i got tons of games to play yeah so
whenever these like big events happen
good or bad
good things happen you know obviously
cm's don't get credit for it when all
these bad things happen
i hate that they're attacked so much
yeah
like what are they supposed to do
they're just the mediators like
stop you know
yeah it's exactly it's a it's a video
game
enjoy it or go try and enjoy something
else don't
don't go don't go crazy so
yeah i was like stasis will be
interesting you know expunge will be
kind of your weekly play and then you'll
keep grinding the
splicer gauntlet for a little bit but
you know if you feel like you've done
everything for the week go see the
sunlight go try other things
play it as much as you play it as much
as you like
to don't get to a point where if you're
not having fun or take a little
do what you're gonna just you know have
fun a little bit but relax
i think this is probably a good place to
probably rap let our man get back to his
world his family and everything else
um so before we go first i want to say
thank you
alan king for coming on we appreciate
it for one making it work because you
know this has been this has been like a
moving target so we finally got you on
here but man it was a pleasure having
you on
so first thing i want to do is thank you
obviously for joining us it's been an
absolute pleasure
and then second piece is let everybody
who's listening know
where they can find you what you got
going on what to expect from you if
there's any like groups that you're like
hey they got some good people want to
join a good place
everything you got going floor is yours
man tell them where they can find you
and what you got going
so thanks for having me and you can have
me again in a heartbeat if you want
i'm just a message away and um
i i i okay i don't know how to say this
i recently started dabbling in variety
games
uh obviously destiny's home this is what
you know i built my own community around
and on
and all my people love destiny and
whether i'm doing patrols or whether i'm
doing
a pvp they're there just talking and
engaging with me
but i've been dipping my feet in other
games as well i've been enjoying it
and then good goals
my biggest goal is to build a space
create a space for creators from india
either before i'm gone or during my time
so other creators from here will have
the space to come and
you know have that support system build
their
you know platforms or whatever that is
my goal
that is my biggest goal and i'm building
towards it
i'm trying to get more creators involved
and i'm trying to
get more people involved in that and um
you can find me at the twitch.tv allen
on twitch on twitter it's the same thing
ex king allen you can find me there
and you can message me at any time
i will make myself available for you if
you need a brother i'll be there
no none of that i'll i'll see you
through if i tell you something i'll see
you through
do you need somebody to talk to i'll be
there like i don't need anything in
return
check me out if i'm entertaining if i'm
not don't
he's like i can only be me hopefully you
like it
salute to you brother because obviously
you know we talked offline and also
begin to show you know we know the
struggle we know what it is and
you know one thing i like about e what
he does is he gets
you know i don't take a lot of credit i
got to give you the credits like he he
really does his homework
and making sure we have a very diverse
lineup of guests and people that we want
to celebrate in the community
and you were one of them you were one of
them you know he brought you to my
attention
i did my research and i'm like wow this
is a cool dude and
i didn't even realize until you mention
it you know as far as
the plight for you know indian content
creators and things of that nature and
you know you putting yourself out there
and and getting that
community together to say hey this is
the safe space
this is where i want to celebrate us and
push it forward
so that there's walking out you know i'm
saying there's more
you know saying people say better people
better people
yeah and it's good to see it's good to
see so salute to e
you know for doing his due diligence as
he always does as the cheetah
you know saying and um yeah salute to
you more importantly for just keeping up
the good work
keeping a positive energy and um also i
love what you do as far as family and
taking care of mental health issues and
things of that nature and being honest
about it because a lot of people are not
honest about that
and when you show that vulnerability
some people can relate because they say
yo
i'll go through that too you know say
it's good because some people act like
it's perfect like there's
no things in the world everything's
great yay no it's real life things going
on in a lot of people's lives and
you you actually bring that out and
you're doing a good job
so salute to you the king you know what
i'm saying
i see i see you exactly yeah
absolutely yeah much love brother much
love
oh absolutely absolutely what do you got
coming up sir
busy man it's a non-stop week for me um
we're getting down into
e3 territory obviously we saw the
horizon
zero dawn joint you know i'm forbidden
west excuse me
um absolutely stunning you know we got
that um
tomorrow tune in if you like rts's
we will have a little special stream on
saturday would be the iron harvest
developers they got a new dlc out called
operation
forgot the day eagle and um the
operation will be out so it'll be the
iron lords of lords of gaming.net
versus the devs little three v three
action just a little fun celebrate the
game and then of course every sunday is
the lord's day
1 p.m eastern check it out we will be
bringing back
the prediction series so sony's up
we're gonna be doing the sony prediction
series we're gonna have some good
content creators
come check us out oh it's gonna be uh
big cloud gaming uh mr bad bit who was
actually all kind of funny salute to him
and recently he actually did his thing
and um mr k step
and of course you know what i'm saying
jay barry so
very playstation centric e you'll be
proud it'll be a nice playstation
central just
talk about predictions what we thinking
what's going on obviously horizon
so sunday 1 p.m eastern check it out on
the lord's day
it'll be fun and of course if you ain't
been listening to that last word
you need to be listening to that last
word because we kind of we kind of
decent content creators if i must say so
myself my man's down with the best gg
salute to him he's out here moving and
shaking cheers cheers to my advanced
brother from across the world over there
exactly advanced boys
i want to say like i'm not saying this
because i'm partnered with them or
whatever they treat their people
really well yes they treat them with
respect they treat them with love
they don't treat you any differently
because of your numbers or whatever they
treat you very well
and people like that you should support
problems whoever support but support the
company absolutely
and i love that he loves the product
that means a lot because i know he's
very finicky there's a man that don't
eat condiments
i guess i get a lot of crap about my
eating disorders
this man advanced chad that's it's all
over
you're doing your thing you got lord
fussy
to co-sign this thing and say it's
amazing
so i can't wait the orders are going to
be coming in yeah shameless pluck
shameless plus
i got to support my man he's out here
doing big things
don't even get me started because
to be able to plug that the work that
goes into it
is a lot you don't get to see it you
should seamlessly plug it bro use use
this code i bought this
you said advanced baby hey i try and be
nice to our guests as well i got chat
covered for me so use cody bontis
you what's your code allen what's yours
ah it's king allen bing allen yeah so
x or just regular kick out just this
king alex yeah use code king allen use
cody bontis
try some out some energy some focus
um yeah i literally used it as
pre-workout this morning
for my kickboxing class so so nasty
mystery right
this is the astor crosses yeah i got
that one
i got this before it was released like
two months before it was released wow
and they told me not to not to show it
on stream not to is
they trusted me yeah that's crazy
that's bro that's huge it's huge just
imagine one day i was like you know this
is a new play
yeah it's it's kind of melanie is the
best way i can describe it
i love it yeah that tastes so amazing
yeah
they have a lot of cool flavors too and
then most
ones that i can tell you it's like if
you look at the label kind of get an
idea
they do a very good job of only putting
out flavors that they really do kind of
hit
they don't just put out some that are
kind of hit or miss they want to nail
every every jar every tub that you get
they do seem to have a really good job
of like you know quality control
which i like quality control yes no
doubt no doubt
he said domain hey we trying brother we
tried i was like
if we ever could that's that's a thing
so yeah hopefully
we'd love to have crossover he's awesome
um
but yeah i mean for me it's simple
obviously you know shout out to advanced
gg use cody bontis um
yeah i don't know what my weekend holds
obviously with my fridge being busted
this weekend's been kind of strange
mass effect is high on the priority list
to jump into for sure believe me i know
um so i want to jump into one definitely
at least get that first hour of just
like
story hit you in the face and see how
much i get knocked in so you guys can
tune in for
destiny and variety streams here on
twitch twitter who knows what i'm doing
on there and then of course on youtube
you guys know guides and other things so
um late lemon berry there's the yeah
there's a lot of flavors
yeah we got some good stuff so uh but
all we got for today
is love for mr king allen thank you very
much for joining us
episode 151 you guys have been awesome
we're going to go raid zoey because
shout out to her or
just another reason i got my first vlog
clear so i got to share the love back
there
yeah they got me through the first time
so my first player was with them and
they made it look way
too easy so yeah yeah they killed it so
yeah we're gonna go see the love over
there
yeah i mean making life simple so we're
gonna go right over there uh but for
this episode number 151 thank you king
allen
may 28th we will be getting into june we
are almost through 20 halfway through
2021 which is crazy
uh shout out to gcx i will be content
creator badged in that one so come hang
out at gcx as well it got approved yes
i'll be there there we go
good times coming up that's all i got to
say so
that boot though was pretty cool my boys
actually made it up at the massacre boys
they got an entire booth for us very
nice
so you guys are awesome thank you guys
very much whether it's youtube twitch
twitter itunes spotify wherever you find
us like it drop a review
follow all of these amazing people and
outside of that for this episode
it has been the last word